Hello sweet bitches of the Internet.
Yeah, that's right. We're back.
This episode is brought
to you by me undies.
This is a disturbing thing that has been
discovered due to an Internet survey is
that most men don't change their
underwear. But once every seven years,
that shit's fucked up. It's more
than that for me. That's fucked up.
That's your Dick Hammocks on.
You need to keep that shit clean.
You don't have a pair of underwear that
you know for sure that you've had for a
long ass time.
I tried to get rid of them,
but um, I'm going to be honest with you.
I never bought nice underwear before.
I just would buy like underwear, like
whatever, like a big packet of m and all.
As they kept my Dick in place,
I get very upset if the dick hole
opens up and I've got to keep talking,
talking the hamster back into
the cage. That was bullshit. Um,
so until these me on these
guys sent me underwear.
These are the best underwear
I've ever worn without a doubt.
And I was thinking about it
when I put them on. I was like,
why wouldn't I want like comfortable
underwear on my balls and my dick like of
wood. Right. So why haven't I not like
spent money on like some nice underwear.
I've never spent money on nice underwear.
I just bought fucking whatever.
So then of these,
me and these guys,
they sent me it and at first I
was like a little bit skeptical.
It's like it's fucking underwear
man who this shit about underwear.
You gotta to get underwear at a store.
But they have like really high quality
shit. Like it feels good like it,
it's like they have moisture like it,
it pulls moisture away from your body.
They're their underwears
like super high end stuff.
You know, I, I, my,
my Dick is being strangled right now and
I think a ball is hanging out and I've
always just accepted like, oh that's
just sitting. That's just your choices.
You've got ropes around your
Dick. What are you talking? No,
my underwears way too tight.
Like this underwear that I'm wearing,
I know I've had for a long time
and it's super, super tight.
You have the same underwear for back when
you lost a ton of weight? Yeah. Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean I have a hundred word I know I've
had for a long time cause it's kind of
like if it's, if it's still
works, why would you throw
it away? It's like a towel.
Well me on disease, your
solutions son. Okay.
And they will pull some moisture away
from your desk and give you some shit that
fit the most comfortable underwear you
have ever tried on. They fit perfectly.
They don't,
they don't strangle you dick safe.
And they literally do pull moisture away
from your skin. So that will help you.
Like with people that have like
yeasty or things going on it.
Well you should probably clean yourself.
You fucking dirty pig.
But once you do do that. Yeah, I mean
guys are diabetes just feels better.
Yeah. A lot of guys, you know how
many guys are diabetes? You blow him.
When I got that mail, yeast infection,
I studied it for a long time.
I'm sure you did.
I'm sure it wasn't honestly cursory use,
little glimpse on a Google
went back to business it,
where did they pull the moisture to?
They take it to Canada.
It's kind of going on them
a lot from Canada. It's just
that's what we give back.
Ball Ball, sweat gutters to this or
like this is your pants just get,
become a wet. It just becomes like
the [inaudible] for ball sweat.
Just captures it all. Anyway, me on
these.com go there. They're underwear.
I'm
wearing them right now. They're very,
very, very comfortable and uh, you know,
change your fucking underwear
more than once every seven years.
Your pigs go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Rogan
before September 1st and
get 20% off your first order,
20% off of your first order when you go
to meet undies.com forward slash Rogen
before September 1st, which is a couple
of weeks from now. All right, fuck,
enjoy me undies.
Dot.
We are also brought to you by Ting Ting
is the official cell phone provider for
this podcast. The phone is, uh, that
we use for this podcast is run on Ting.
Ting is, um, the use of sprint backbone.
And they use it with their own rules,
their own rules like that.
They decide, they decided,
okay, let's have no contracts,
et cetera.
No early termination fees.
Let's not even charge people like a
set amount per month. Um, let's do it.
They did it two different ways.
One, at one point in time,
they would like credit you, they would
knock you down to the lower level.
Like say if you didn't
use all your minutes,
they're knocking down to a lower level
and credit either distance the difference
on your next bill. And then he decided
like, that's too fucking complicated.
But you know what it really should be.
It should be people just pay for what
they use. So that's their newest thing,
which I think is perfect.
And I think that's where all cell
phone providers will eventually find
themselves. It doesn't make any sense.
It'd be like, you pay for 120 minutes.
We only use a hundred. Where's those
20 minutes? They're gone. They're,
they're evaporated. But with
Tang, 98% of people use tangled,
saved money. And, uh, again,
they use the sprint backbone,
they rent time on sprints or it's a major
network and they do it in like a very
ethical way, in a way that, uh,
just makes you feel good about
working with the company.
I think that's how it should be.
Like contracts and termination fees and
all this legal bullshit with telling you
buy a phone, you have [inaudible]
by phone, you have it, it's yours.
And then if you want to cancel,
then we tell them,
go fuck yourself and you just cancel and
that's it. And you're in, you're out,
you do whatever you want to do. That's
how it should be. You know, this, uh,
this idea about, you
know, being able to, uh,
control people with contracts. It's
fucking gross. I don't like it.
I don't like it,
Brian.
Oh, I get it. It's so cheap though.
And they have family plants now where you
can like add somebody for really cheap.
So if you have a girlfriend you get,
throw her on your plan, check it out.
You can just go to plan.
It's going to take a look at
the different points. Rogan,
[inaudible] dot com if you go there,
you could see all the different
cell phones they sell as well.
Like Brian was showing them on
the screen earlier. They have, um,
like some serious high end android phones.
The one I got is the Samsung Galaxy
s five. I just got it. Love it.
You know what else I love about it?
It's water resistant. Like it did the,
the bottom of it. It plugs in and
you can throw it in the toilet
if you want it to.
It'll be okay.
He use it as toilet paper and throw it
allowed to do that until you can't wipe
your ass on it. Cause then you'll
get like, but if he just dropped it.
Have you ever dropped your
phone at the moment? I've
dropped my phone. Yeah, I got,
yeah, we all have while on poop and
I had to grab it. Yeah. Yeah. I've,
I've dropped it while brushing
my teeth in the sank and
got water all over it.
I fucked phones up before dropping them.
But with, um, these, uh, galaxy s five,
you don't have to worry about that.
Actually the bottom closes
ups got a little tab that
closes in on the bottom and
the top. Apparently you can go under
water with these fucking things.
A lot of people think I was stupid.
I said that story about having to
suck the water out of my phone. Like,
cause a lot of people throw it in rice
and I'm always like get the water out of
their first smart and sweet.
But a lot of people have said that that
was the dumbest thing they ever heard.
And so I went online to all this
Howard forms and I researched it. No,
that totally makes sense.
Get the water out of there.
Maybe he's a vacuum
cleaner if you have one,
probably wouldn't be as good as your
mouth because your mouth would seal it,
you know,
and you could get a good amount of yeah,
I can get a good amount of
suction with that. Yeah.
And just fucking be a man about it. And
you know, brushing teeth afterwards,
you know,
suck your phone at least go has invented
this pack that you put a phone in.
If it's got wet and you put it in this
in more liquid, which sounds crazy,
but it counteracts what the was doing.
Absolutely bizarre.
I was apparently it would have been
huge because their plan was to put it in
airports but because it's a bag of liquid.
Oh did you go cause cause,
cause I really like the perfect thing to
have an [inaudible] but yeah you put it
in and it's so yeah, we count
as well. What does someone else,
so it's not just, it's the, it's
not just the fact it's liquid,
it's something in it that
erodes everything wearing
I wonder what it is.
I remember they were doing those
things where there were dipping phones.
You remember that you'd send off a
phone to a company. They still do that.
They even sell it now. I'd just like
Lowe's. You can buy the same chemical now.
Real. Yeah. You could dip your own phone.
Yeah. I think we should the commercial on,
on this pond. No, no. Did we? Yeah,
I wasn't paying attention. I
was trying to avoid, you know,
I don't remember that at all man.
I really don't.
They sell it now and do it yourself.
Yeah.
They said you did it on one
of your spots. No, no, no.
I remember it cause we talked about
it and we set a commercial about,
I don't remember. Just been too
many God damn podcast. Fuck. So how,
how hard is it to do? Is it easy?
Like you just, yeah, it's pretty easy.
You can just do that then. I don't know.
You can like different clothes in it.
Like if you work outside a lot, your
shoes, your, your, your shoes. So you do,
you throw the whole phone
in this bullshit. Are you?
Because what about the screen? Is it fuck
with a screen? I don't, I don't know.
Here I'll show you what you did. No,
let's just get through this commercial.
People are mad p I get some of my tweets
about how long these commercials are
tough shit.
You know how to use
the fast forward bitch.
Use a anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot ting.com and
save 25 bucks off of any of their, uh,
awesome new phones,
rogan.ting.com in Joe yet.
And that's it.
This episode,
the podcast that commercials are now
officially over scrupulous pip is here.
Let's just get cracking with
this thing. Well, shall we
experience,
try my day job.
What's happening in fellow. I'm
good man. How you doing? It's been
cool to talk to you from the moment
you got here 20 plus minutes ago.
Been hanging out with, did
a lot of talking. Yeah,
Jack Black was a really cool dude at
tennis and some crazy stories of Russia,
but yeah. Yeah, he's tired.
He was telling us some,
Robin black was telling us some
awesome stories of uh, these, uh,
Russian dudes that, uh, he
partied with these sumo wrestlers.
It was insane that like what what he was
saying was like, it was so ridiculous.
The stories of access and drinking and
waking up covered in urine. And uh,
we videotaped it. So a Jamie, Jamie,
Jamie, we'll put that shit up later,
but it was really funny. He was a, he was
a cool dude, man. I really liked Robin.
Yeah. Interesting guy. Um, from
another country he is as our user. Yes.
Indeed.
I am all the way from England.
I saw your shit on my message board was
the first time I saw your shit. Yeah.
Some people would put up a, one
of the videos was a view. Uh,
you're cutting your hair. Yeah.
You're in Walsh and introduction.
That's a great fucking [inaudible]. That's
really fun. A hundred pounds on that,
on that video did you, was my complete
budget. Can we play that? Play that?
Let's play that and talk about it.
Brian. Pull it up. It's a introduction.
You got to tell them how to spell it.
This is my foot was row
for picking the name.
This ridiculously hard to spell
and pronounce and yeah, it's,
it's scribbious pips. A tough one for
Twitter's. No easy, no easy to fit in.
Some people do. They try. Oh, you,
yeah, yeah. They try ous. Yeah. Mm.
Screws. Yeah, they get it
in the end. Eventually.
Here we go.
So the dead fish on the pavement and for,
what did you expect?
There's no wall around these stupid.
She just stayed where it was wet.
You gotta see this.
I don't to leave miss pip and I would
like to see some deliveries into this
microphone.
This amplified so you can he read
his piece of diction is the Intro to
distraction pieces or some of the shit
that flies around my head and keeps me
seamless. It's actually often for
former fucking brain fools anorexic.
So many typers. When our right
a wall claim. I'm dyslexic.
I'll go you poem here.
I've put it in December.
I'm setting fire to wait and
hope you all can read the smoke.
Most people where my live don't
know me and I fucking like it.
Some people were barley formuli
me how to fucking nowhere.
Somebody for an open naval
[inaudible] retention
[inaudible] they are just words.
You give them power
was covered by Lilly.
Pros is original. Now
I'm repeating what I say.
This could
be an excuse to run into this all
brandished the [inaudible] vista,
right?
Benny
[inaudible] too intrusive.
You see a mouse trap?
I'll see free cheese and a
fucking challenge you say
[inaudible] that is great.
That's really fun man.
I really enjoy that. I thought the
lyrics are cool. I like how I did it.
It was interesting and crazy because we've
failed that in just a metal container
and the guard who had rented the off,
we didn't tell him what the fuck we were
doing cause I figured we can only do it
in one take because I've got
a shaved my head and shit.
So I thought if be doesn't, if we ask
him, he can say no. Right. If we do it,
he can just tell us off afterwards
and, and that's that. So as you finish,
obviously there's tons of fire.
We say Cheryl farm,
we have to have the doors closed because
of in, oh, so in a metal container,
which was burned and everything.
And then our powered out with smoke
bellowing and the guy just walked past and
sweat pip. I don't even want to
know more Tom. Like good man.
Good man. The die. What a great scene.
You coming out of a video shoot,
shaved
your head shaved.
And the fucking door opens to a storage
container in this smoke bellowing out.
What a great scene. That's rock and
roll, man. That's some real shit.
The beauty of direct in all your own
videos is you don't have to do health and
safety sheet. You don't have
to take that off, isn't it?
There's no one to say you can't do that.
It's like, yeah, we can fucking do that.
You, how did you get started
rapping, man, we'll let you, do you,
do you consider that rap or you kind of,
I mean, I started off in spoken word,
so I started off just kind of weave,
no beat spies into hip hop. And again,
a lot of people hear spoken word and
think that sales shit basically and poetry
in it. But I was exactly the same.
Um, spoken word has potential, right?
What do people like being people love?
I have a dream.
I have a dream is God damn spoken word.
I mean Martin Luther King's
I have a dream speech,
which is why I always refer
to it as spoken word are
rather than poetry anything.
Because that's the most literal
right. Jan, I mean a really an,
an intricate stand up set. This like
one piece that's a whole story. That's,
that's spoken word.
It's just does not word poetry does poet,
does that have a bad connotation?
Like a pretentious kind of tapers off
from people kind of think you're dead,
right?
If you say,
I remember I was at the comedy cellar
in New York and David tells onstage and
he's killing and there's this snotty
fucking the audience and for some reason
the guide took offense to want to Dave's
jokes and says something and, and uh,
Dave was like, well I'm sorry
sir. I'm just trying to hear.
You're trying to do some
jokes. What do you do for a
living, sir? No, he's fucking,
the guy goes, I'm a poet published
and I'll never forget that.
I never for a year I would say
that to people. I'm a poet,
published like trying to get
insurance and shit like that.
I'd just try and explain what I do and
then just go with unemployed or self
employed cause itself. They put
poetry on Ma. Oh my thing, this,
I'll never forget that asshole.
I'm a poet published and he had like
fashionable clothes on shit. You know,
he's just totally lives at
home still with his mom.
[inaudible] David Tell doesn't even
remember it. But I remember it.
It wasn't even me that got
heckled fuck heads. But yeah,
so obviously I'm not in love with poetry.
I started doing it because
I was in kind of like some,
some punk bands and shit like that and
I got sick of relying on dramas that mum
like giving them a lift to practice and
the basis can't make it because he's
working in night shift and shit like that.
So I was looking at what I could
do and succeed or fail on my own.
Like I love the buzz of the fact that if
it went well, it's my fault if I fail,
I can't say always this other guy's fault.
That's a real problem with bands, Huh?
Yeah.
Eddie Bravo was trying to explain to me
like the trials and tribulations at the
average band goes through and I was
thinking about it when we had the
conversation. I'm like, I never
even thought about that before.
But dealing with all those egos together
and then also some people that are just
undisciplined. Yeah, completely.
Some people aren't as passionate about
it as you are or it's just a fun thing
for them and equally accepting
gigs and shit and shit like that.
You have to ring through like
four or five other people to say,
can we accept this Gig
site? Yeah. Soulful, full.
To me that's kind of why I started
doing spoken word. Um, yeah.
So I could do it all off of my own bath.
It was just a height of
being in bands really.
They know what I like
about what you did to, um,
for whatever reason there's a lot of guys
who speak a certain way and then when
they performed wrap, it sounds like
an urban black guy. Yeah, completely.
Very strange.
It's like what?
What happened that you had to start
doing it like this because that's not how
you would talk in real life.
Miss, I was raised in the hood,
but I'm strong from my, you know,
it's, there's, there's like,
it blows my mind that people,
the most common thing that people say
to me after shows and that is like, oh,
you sound exactly. I like doing recall.
Does that, cause this is my voice.
This is me talking this article about
why, uh, people with a British accent
sing in an American accent. You know,
I don't remember what the fucking
conclusion was. I barely, essentially,
I looked at it, I'm like, who cares? They
just choose to, you know, you could chew,
but if there's a difference between an
English guy choosing to sound American
and American guy choosing
to sound British,
cause if an English guy comes over to
America and loses his British accent,
nobody's gonna give him
a hard time about it.
But if an American got takes on a
British accent, get the fuck outta here.
But Madonna can live in London. Tiller
tits, fall off. You're not British.
Cut it out. Cut it out.
Cut it out. Madonna.
Don't feel fucking bought a house there.
That rich bitch,
she bought a house there just so
she could talk in an English accent.
I just want to be one of the loads.
Come on my,
I am Madonna. I am a dancer. Slash singer.
Slash superstore was
Madonna Madonna at night.
Did she should be hand fucking,
what's his name?
Elton John was listening to a
country comfort on the way over here.
Just randomly sometimes like my iPhone
syncs up with my a car, just a play.
You know,
how does it,
sometimes I'll just play random song
and it just started playing. Um,
it's on one of my playlists,
but that Elton John Song,
country comfort that mother
fucker cause sing his ass off.
God Damn Elton John's good.
You're just like,
there's so much emotion and power in
his songs, you know, it's just like,
it takes you right to what he said.
He's thinking like it's a bout grandma
and needing help to fix her barn.
You know like this and you like you
see in the whole thing play out.
You see in fields of wheat and butterflies
and an old lady and Elton John's a
bad motherfucker.
Does he stay on lockout and Joan and
when he sings, that's not really right.
It's kind of, it's not really an
American accent though, is it?
It's Kinda hard to say. Hard to say
because the, when you're singing you're,
you're extending these words.
She needed me. He sang farm and it's
taken him like 10 seconds. Yeah.
Sneeze him helped him on the phone.
Nobody talks like that.
Yeah. So it's like I've got to start. I,
so I do kind of talk a lot about this.
This might end up in a really long
podcasts that normally three hours,
this will be like six hours, seven
hours. So lock yourselves in,
sing into weird thing, man.
Singing is a beautiful thing,
but spoken word to music is a very
different thing. Spoken word to music.
It's very lyrical. Um, uh,
lyrically dependent. That's
the word for it. It's like,
that was what I really enjoyed about
your stuff was it was very clever.
I could see that you put a lot of thought
into the your lyrics and what you're,
you know, and I love the thing about
Lenny Bruce, it's like, you know,
you covered it in a really cool way.
It's kind of neat.
Also tell it was one take [inaudible]
w whenever I'm running and he's,
the main goal was to make you
interested in, to me kind of thing.
And that's why I think confuses me about
a lot of hip hop when it is all just
talking about the same thing.
It's like I'd get bored performing that
or doing that over and over again. So
it's kind of, you know what that
exists. I think in every art form.
I bet it exists in rock and roll. I
bet. I mean, I know it exists in comedy,
you know,
there's,
there's certain subjects that guys will
cover when you can tell they're covering
it because they think that the
audience wants to hear that. Yeah.
And it's not like what's actually
interesting to them. Yeah.
I can't imagine getting excited finishing
the line or finishing a piece of,
that's just exactly that kind of,
I think people enjoy that.
There's a lot of people
that do do that though.
It's weird like those hip
maker guys so like sit down,
they write these songs that they know
specifically we'll hit like a target
nurses understand that cause cause they've
run that for someone else to have to
perform and resale. They're sold every
night to kind of sing and get through.
I can understand that
because they just go,
I'm going to write this to make a fuck
ton of money and then hand this over to
some other guy to wasn't there a home up
there and wasn't there a band where the
lead singer was like one of those guys
that would like write songs for a lot of
like train didn't isn't
that what I'm thinking of
now? But what it was that there's
this, what the fuck was trained?
There was this one band.
Fuck I'm not going to remember.
I'm not going to remember.
But I remember this as big as
the one who writes the songs for,
well he made headway in our work does,
he released himself and it was
pretty recently and it was a big hit,
but it was like one of
those songs were like,
I couldn't get into it cause
it was like it was well done,
but I could tell that it was like a
calculated things ticking over the book
cause he's got formula
that makes it worse. Yeah.
As opposed to like there's certain
songs you know where like you don't,
you don't even know why you like it.
Like there's this, um, there's this, uh,
old Leonard Skinner Song, the battle of
Curtis Lowe. Yeah. You know, and it's,
it's one of those songs were like you,
the battle ballad rather of Curtis Lowe
and it's one of those songs. We hear it.
You don't even know what is going on
that this song is just captivating me in
such a unique way.
Like cha making me emotional,
like making me feel that moment and tell
when they feel like that'd been written.
A lot of that.
Like one of the things I liked about the
way that song introduction kind of blew
up was no one kind of notice for
ages that it's not got a chorus,
it's not got a hook, right.
It's no good anything.
And he was kind of that people didn't
notice that because they were kind of
captivated and into it and
didn't think about all right,
you meant a kind of go verse, chorus
verse, Chorus, bridge, you know,
this kind of shit.
So it's kind of Nice when that works
and you can tell it's just, he's just,
uh, just what came out and
what was natural. But you
pieced that together, right?
Like that's a piece. Like
you started working on that,
you've developed it. Do you,
when you, when you do something
like that and you develop a piece,
do you write it all out and like what,
like how long is that whole song is
about three and a half months or so.
Three and a half minutes.
Yeah. And do you,
do you develop it at three and a half
minutes? Do you add to it along the way?
Because it completely written before
you ever get to the stage.
Yes.
It's all completely written
before I get to this stage.
A lot of of that song in particular,
I mean I'm no in stuff on my phone
all the time. Um, and just, yeah,
am making note of just good lines
are good ideas or topics or subjects.
I'd be have like a new line I just pops
into your head and you want to add just
Mike and I mean in Emma notes.
Otherwise I'm going to have
something awful in there now. Um,
but it would just be notes even if it's
just even if it didn't align or a turn
of phrase I on my last note was saying
about how loads of rappers at the moment
of going on about game based mode,
beast mode be anything.
I've just written one sign through
one about going Depeche mode.
They said that's literally,
there's no lyric.
They have no structured that
yet but right. It's just right.
I'll do something with that.
So they don't have a song about that.
Cause a lot of my songs are stories
as well though. So, but one like that,
it's easy to go through these kinds of
weird little ideas or phrases or even
like my bitsa philosophy and shit
and shit like that just to go right.
I'll put that in there.
Right.
That's the coolest thing about
creating your own stuff right. As it,
you could just decide what goes in,
you could decide. And it's just,
I mean,
the thing that I buzzed about it the
most is that you don't know what's good
until you put it out there
by genuinely on, on that one,
there's a line or you see a mouse trap.
I see free cheese and F if I can challenge
it was just one of loads of lines.
And then when that came out,
it's the one that everyone was going
crazy on and everyone was tweeting.
So I had no idea that that was the
standout because you're so in it that,
yeah. Yeah. It's got so
much to you put it together.
So that was one of many stand
now that the whole thing,
there's a lot of great lyrics in that,
but yeah,
that's definitely a standout
part of it. That's, uh,
that's, that's really cool man.
I love anything like that where it's
like one guy piecing something together,
whether it's music or whether it's
a book like talking to an author,
but creating a book or whether it's a
stand up comedian creating an act or a guy
writing a, uh, you know,
moving or anything. It's just,
there's something about that creative
process so much more now with us.
So much more acceptable and doable because
of the Internet and because of being
out to get whatever your one passion is
out there that you can kind of just be,
it doesn't have to be a team of right
as a team of people doing this and that
you can find a lot more people who've got
that just one vision and then just see
where it turns into. Yeah. Yeah.
And when you like have this one thing
that comes out of your own mind and you
put it together and you, it's like we
were talking about this with comedy.
Like when somebody becomes a pip fan,
like you're the only one that can give
them that stuff like that. Then she,
they were looking to see what comes out
of your head. Yeah. You know, as crazy as,
as, as, as well though. And I get,
I'm sure it's the same with stand up.
It's that weird thing of all of it.
As much as you put into it,
it's just what you think at the time.
So a,
but then it's committed to record and
that's that. So five years down the line,
my opinions or views by odd hope, my
opinions and views will change in general,
let on everything.
But I think it's important to develop
ideas and philosophies are constantly,
so it's in that weird thing
that people will have got that,
that first record and being of listened
to that one phrase or thing over and
over and it's become their kind of
mantra. And then you're like, yeah,
I kind of know into that as much anymore.
I'm kind of delving into this shit now.
This is what's going on now. And
this, it's weird how that, yeah,
that can be the thing that you can either
give them what they need or you can't,
if you know what I mean. Right.
It's natural development.
Hip Hop seems to be in a way a lot like
standup comedy in that it's kind of
generic and turn. Yup. But it's
very broad in terms of content.
It's very completely stupid paper who
say I love comedy or I love hip hop.
You'd have specific comedy and a specific
hip hop. There's loads of shit, comedy,
there's loads of shit. Hip Hop, there's
loads of shit. Shit, shit, spoken word.
I like good comedy problems.
Right. You know, I've got my
specifics I like, so yeah,
it's, it's another one that a guy, um,
I work with sometimes sage Francis
was saying in an interview recently,
it's got to the point now where
when people talk about hip hop,
you can't assume that they're talking
about the same thing as him. And again,
I think that's because it's so broad.
There's such a variation in there. Yeah.
Yeah. There's a giant broad variation
and it's interesting. It's like a,
if you went to a club and it
just said rock and roll, we'll,
you'd know it would be rock and roll.
But if you went to a club just said music,
well hip hop is like,
it's such a very specific type of music,
but inside the genre there's like a bunch
of different variables, right? Yeah,
hugely.
Again,
when our I f I first started off and I
was talking about and trying to get my
name out there,
I'd struggled to describe what I do
because if I said hip hop and people
instantly thought with 50 cent or
cane because of 50 cent or candies,
like you're not going to
be happy with what you get.
Or equally they might be put off because
they're not into that and it's like,
well this might not be right. They
might think that you would, you know,
you'd be affecting a certain type
of behavior and exactly. They think,
I'm going to speak in an American accent
and B, are you allowed to say wicker?
Is that, is it a, is wigger a a white guy?
Liga has it become an issue?
It doesn't seem like it.
Like you can call someone that and it's
not like dropping an n bomb. Right? Like,
even though it sounds a lot like it
with a w you're allowed to let us slide.
It's fine and don't have a heart,
but there is that kind and
then there's what you're doing,
which is like a completely
different thing.
Like you're talking and
you're making sure Brian,
but you're also making statements
and it's very entertaining,
but it says it's a form of hip hop,
but it's a very different form of hip hop.
Yeah, yeah, completely. And it's key.
It's the entertainment part is key as
well because I think a lot of people who
do the more conscious stuff, it's
just like, yeah, it's a lecture.
You know what I mean?
You kind of just being fed this
and it feels like they can't.
Trying to get across just how
intelligent they are and all this.
I'm kind of in all my stuff. It's trying
to open up discussion rather than say,
here's the the beginning and end of,
of
of this subject.
It's kind of saying like there's some
shit that we should maybe all think about
a bit more or discuss a musical culture
in general more but not trying to say
I've got all the answers. Here's, yeah,
here's my shake I name. Yeah. Yeah.
I love the fact that there's so many
different genres in hip hop now cause I
think that uh, I've always been a fan
of, I'm a fan of all kinds of different,
like I'm a fan of your style but I'm also
like a big fan of like old school Geto
boys, you know, completely.
I've got over a radio. Damn.
It feels good to be a gangster.
Came on the radio the other day and
I was like fuck, this is the shit.
This song is the shit.
That's how you,
for fingers when I'm in La is because
you've got radio stations that just play
just old hip hop and proper kind of
hip hop or all day long and yeah,
I don't have that in the UK.
I miss Scarface.
Scarface still putting out shit is
a new track like six months ago too.
I'm need to,
I need to get back in scar face.
I forgot what a good rapper
he a diary was. Damn.
It feels good to be against that.
And that album cover with the
guy's eyeball hanging out. Yeah.
We can't be stopped. Geto
boys, man. That's Bushwick.
Bill shot himself in the eye there.
They were the craziest.
Yeah, that was some
fun fucking music, man.
My mind is playing tricks
on me, dude. Dude, dude.
I was Joe. I was at, when I
was in at Florida for doing
comedy just last weekend,
there was this fetish con going on
and so it was like Mark Marin, uh,
you know Chris harder going,
a few of us just all hanging out
this bar watching all these freaks.
It was like being at like a AVN with
dominatrix is and people in gimp suits and
stuff like that. Wow.
And there was this woman,
this guy that was dressed up as a woman
with a face mask on and she just stared
at us and didn't move in the face.
Masks had this creepy like smile on it.
And it was the most disturbing thing ever.
I have a photo of it somewhere.
Just fetish people.
Yeah, just fetish people.
And then in Jacksonville I went
to this borough bar and uh,
there was a band that was about to start
in the next room and out of nowhere
this band jumps off stage and goes into
the room that the bar area that we're at
and starts playing right into the crowd,
like jumping on like,
like the tables of the bar and stuff.
And then at the end they caught the
symbols on fire and that place was like on
fire. It was the most intense,
amazing band I've ever seen.
And it was just like a band. I just popped
into a bar and saw this amazing band.
And so if you should check out
the video sometime of them,
they're really interesting band, but
it's cool seeing like libraries, music,
combat. Uh, their name is doc. Oh, hold
on. I want to make sure I say this right.
Daca Sui or something like that.
It's a
hello here. I'll get it to
you. Yeah. People online that
are listening. Yeah, yeah.
Here I'll find it. I'll find the proper
spelling. I'll be right back. Okay.
All right.
Um,
I don't know where the fuck we were going
before you just derailed Gary. Sorry.
It's
d a n I k a.
J
you and the inside that's me is pip
was tough, Huh? Yeah, right. Bam.
That's ridiculous. And here, here's
actually them playing outdoors,
which is completely
different than what you'd
normalcy. The lead singer. The guy right
there in the face mask hasn't seen mass.
That was at the fetish con that was
just staring at us the whole time.
Wow.
This is kind of wow.
Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you could imagine the Admin,
a small bar and like things are on fire
in front of you moms. These are good.
These guys are good.
That's a bad mother fucker.
[inaudible]
you couldn't hear and you didn't hear
sound and you were trying to figure out
what the fuck to make this totally silent.
Imagine if you didn't hear sound and you
see all this moving around and see all
these people staring at these guys just
playing with these sticks in their hands.
You'd be like, what the fuck
is going on? On that stage?
Why is everybody watching that? It,
it's this, it's a weird Gig, man.
You're creating cool sounds with a stick.
Yeah. You get this big piece of wood,
you creating wild sounds with it. That's
really interesting. Here's, here's how I
[inaudible] just walking
around the whole entire bar
wireless and they can be different
guys. Then maybe even have
to do these guys get cocky.
The fucking put a mask on a new dude
firearm and it's good to see that is
learned and moved up to wireless because
clearly the code was restricted him in
the first one as he
wanted to go run around.
Here's I'm on top of the bar. He was like
doing this shape. That's cool. One fire.
He was like just leaning on like
sitting on my lap for the most.
That's wild.
Yeah. So check them out so they
don't sing. They just play out.
They just jam like fucking crazy
dude. Like style almost. Yeah.
So their name is d.
A. N. I. K. A. I. J. U. D.
I like that man. I like that
idea. That's pretty cool.
I love that they've got hard
and aim. To me. That's right.
That's even though you spell it out
twice now. I've no idea what the name is.
Arnold Schwarzenegger's to good
fallback. It doesn't matter. It doesn't,
it doesn't run shit doesn't mean shit.
Yeah.
Crazy neighbor fuckers. Yeah. It's a
weird thing. And then like the names,
it's important to write the
right the right letters and
words never tell if it's,
it's, it's like if, if, if,
if the doors is a good name or it's a
good name because of the doors, Jeremy.
And if so if you were at some shitty Gig
in the local band and the door's never
happened and they were called the doors,
it probably wouldn't be as, as, uh,
as awesome as it is. Right. It's,
isn't it fascinating though?
The names are about picking
a pleasant sound. Yeah.
That you can remember.
And it's easy to replicate with letters.
Like if you have too many, like what
is this Dika what the fuck is this?
Get out of here with that shit, dude.
No one's going to remember that shit.
And you go anything more about
it now because of the Internet.
Because if you pick a name that too
familiar than when you Google it,
you're going to get, yeah. You know some
crazy. Yeah, whatever it is you've chosen.
Yeah. Right. Stricted yeah.
Especially if you, and what is,
how does it work when you hear bands
of the same name as other bands?
I never know.
I guess someone has to argue it.
You know like the love assassins like
this must be like more than one love
assassins. See original regional
love assessment, you know,
I mean I just need that name
up but I'm sure it exists.
I'm not the first person that think that
way. Right. That's a path that's like,
that's like looking at like a section
of street and trying to imagine that no
one ever walked down, that somebody
walked down that I might not have seen it,
but it's happened.
So like how many different guys could
come up with something like the love
assassins, you know, you've
just got up become the biggest,
I love assassins out there that
you're going to be the biggest ones.
Then the Yahoo, the love assessments.
Do you think there was another kiss?
Like kiss seems like a go or have been,
had to have been at least one other band
thought about becoming the name kiss
set. Probably if he, if,
if somebody kind of retired
or not as popular now you
could just be like, hey no,
my name's Nwa now and just
because you're more popular,
you could kind of would win at that
argument. Right. I don't know man.
I think that's probably trademarked
because it's such a huge business.
But I think like when you're first
coming up and you don't have any legal
paperwork,
that's when it's only an issue.
Cause like if you tried
to be Jimi Hendrix today,
they'd be like shut the fuck up
pitch change manager. But no, I'm,
that's my new name is Jimi Hendrix. I'm
Jimmy Hendrix. But they would be like,
no Jimmy Hendry you can't be a musician
and be Jimi Hendrix. There's fucking,
there's a copyright on that shit.
But I could be milli Vanilli.
Well no one wants to be so I bet
they would just let you. Yeah.
Have you tried to be Milli Vanilli but
I bet [inaudible] owns that shit. Like,
say if you and Jamie
decided to go on tour as Millie and
vanilla and you started doing with like,
you would lip sync and other people would
sing the songs. You get your ass sued.
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. If he
only did like the vanilla part,
even vanilla, they probably own Milli
Vanilli they owned both of those. Yeah.
Yeah. They own it. Don't
you think they own it, Ross?
Well,
Rick Ross is different because Rick Ross,
the original Rick Ross was not a rapper.
I mean,
that's the whole reason why he has those
tee shirts that say Rick Ross is not a
wrap.
He was just unsigned. He wrapped
all the time in the shower. I bet.
[inaudible] Christmas
time. He was rapping. Well,
he was a notorious drug dealer,
a genuine nice guy. I really
like Rick Ross. He's a cool guy.
He's got a book out now. By the way,
if, uh, if anybody's interested, um,
Rick has a brand new book and people
have been asking us to get him on the
podcast again and we wish definitely
should. Um, Rick Ross book,
I'm just giving them plug
the real Rick Ross freeway,
Rick Ross, I'm told by the, yeah,
the untold autobiography, that's
what it's called. And he's a,
he's got a fascinating story
if you're interested. His,
his story is he was the connection
between the Iran Contra affair and selling
drugs in Los Angeles.
He was one of the connections he was
being supplied by a guy who was channeling
that money that he made from Rick
Ross directly into foreign operations.
It's crazy. The whole story is crazy.
And the dude, when he went to jail,
didn't even know how to read. Okay.
And in jail, taught himself at a read,
then became a fucking legal expert
and found the loopholes in his,
uh,
in his prosecution where they fucked up,
found holes in the prosecution's angle
and craziness from God himself off.
Got himself out.
They hadn't been like a three
strike situation and he, uh,
he got out of that because
it has to be three sentences.
It can't be three crimes as
three sentences. So they, they,
they prosecuted for him. It, it,
they prosecuted him for it illegally.
It was incorrect use of the prosecution.
It's kind of weird though than that
he wouldn't have educated himself or
potentially wouldn't have educated himself
in such a manner as if he hadn't been
been put away. So it's kind of, it's
odd to come out of that with, you know,
improved and better and yeah.
Yeah. He's a fascinating case.
It's a very fascinating case and
he's a very good guy to, you know,
put up with Rick Ross or using your name
and they have all these sued him and
lost,
which is really crazy.
I mean one will have a mom,
I'm sure he'll be able to tell us.
I don't know if they're a continuing
the lawsuit. Well maybe we can.
Right. It's a weird one with that
cause it's more of a regular names.
Jimmy Hendrix that's there. You know,
you're not going to hear that every day.
But Rick Ross,
it feels like it'd be a tougher one to,
to sue over cause yeah, I dunno. Yeah.
Rick Ross when lawsuit
against freeway, Rick Ross. Wow. Freeway.
Rick Ross lost his lawsuit against Rapper
Rick Ross born William Leonard Roberts
on first amendment grounds the
case. Wow. First amendment grounds,
freedom of speech. So I guess you're
allowed to take on the persona of a,
a known drug dealer because it's like,
it's a persona.
So it's like artistic expression
that it's like Bonnie and Clyde Shit.
You know,
like I can probably call myself Bonnie and
Clyde or by, yeah. But if they were old
live, would you be able to, you know?
Yeah. But the full name Rick Ross,
the Real Rick Ross knew about the
entertainers stage names since 2006 Oh,
that case originally began in 2010 and
later appeal to a higher court after the
lawsuit was ruled untimely.
Since the real Rick Ross knew about the
entertainer stage names since 2006 so
the idea was that the first time it was
ruled untimely because he didn't act
quick enough, you know, but I think
that there was, there was some issues,
the real Rick Ross said,
where he had talked to Rick Ross and like
he was going to be compensated for it.
Right. And then memory said he
was going to chop it up with him.
Remember that he said, we'll
chop it up, we'll chop it up.
Like he was gonna give him some money
and then he decided not to and then
decided to go to lawsuits with them.
So fucking shady.
Explain why he took time over it and
why he got around to that. But yeah,
that and now that is a very
different sort of a hip hop.
Yeah, completely pick any say
hip hop I love is everywhere.
Is that the people think that just because
I do a certain kind of hip hop that I
think every kind of hip hop should
be like that. It'd be boring as hell.
Liberal Hippo.
I was out that you after to have
the variation in the genre and yeah.
How much do you think the real Rick Ross,
she'd get paid by the fake Rick Ross?
Like if you were the judge?
Half depends how much the holy shit.
That's crazy. That's like being
married to, that's too much,
much.
Maybe 10% though. 10% might
not be upset. 10% seems fast.
Look, you didn't even have to
wrap less. That dude uses name.
That dude makes him more popular.
Here's the thing about the real Rick Ross.
Emotional sweet. You're a sweet
guy. I like him a lot about you.
But here's the thing about,
um,
like think about the real Rick Ross
like we know about the real Rick Ross
because his story is fascinating and we've
talked to him and he's an interesting
guy,
but we also know about the real Rick Ross
because the fake Rick Ross got famous
as fuck with the same name.
Yeah.
So how much would you know about Rick
Ross if he wasn't getting fucked over by
the fake Rick Ross? I
submit, not nearly as much.
I submit that quite honestly,
the f the real Rick Ross has benefited
substantially from the fake Rick Ross
using his name.
And it actually makes him even more legit
because this fake fat rapper used to
be a d,
a corrections officer is using his shit.
I think the tie their table,
that table has kind of changed
a little since Rick Ross,
the fake Rick Ross has now become
who he is. He's like, you know, big,
he is now a huge moneymaker.
So now 10% I think is completely fair and
everyone should just be happy and have
dinner together and maybe
going to go on tour together.
But the, the real Rick Ross, the
real Rick, the original drug dealer,
Rick Ross is benefiting substantially
like publicity wise to being connected
with this. I mean, he has
an amazing story on his own,
but the reality is that this store is
made more compelling by the fact that
there's a guy running around stealing
his name. He's benefited from it.
It's really crazy when you think
about it, you know, and I wonder if,
what the thinking of the time of it,
what was the,
when he probably first heard of this,
this rapper Rick Ross,
he probably didn't think it was
that huge deal. But then when it,
when Rick Ross becomes one of
the biggest rappers in the world,
then suddenly that's,
that's a change during this part of it.
Or why would he always had been trying to
fight the, I think he always, you know,
names even when he came out of
jail, Rick Ross was famous. Yeah.
He just wasn't as famous as he is now.
He's become really super. But yeah,
his book I'm sure wouldn't be
what it is if it wasn't for, well,
the story is amazing. The story
itself is amazing. I mean,
he was a tennis standout in high school,
couldn't go to college
because he couldn't read.
So he was an athlete and was like
stranded in this terrible neighborhood.
Didn't know what the fuck to do.
So he started selling drugs and became
this giant truck dealer and he was making
like some insane amounts of money,
millions of dollars a week. I mean,
he was just making just stupid money
and it was all being funneled to the,
the United States law,
all these covert operations overseas and
in Nicaragua, it's crazy. I mean, it was,
uh, the whole Oliver Stone
of the whole, um, uh, uh,
Reagan Contra Fair. And, um, the fuck's
his name? Oliver. What's his name?
Stone. No, the all over north. Thank you.
The Oliver North situation,
these guys on trial in front
of the fucking tired country.
No one's ever seen that shit
before. You know, and Reagan,
they're asking him if he sold
arms to through other, other,
other countries and shit. This was all
like part of that same era, you know,
the same era of all this
crazy shit going on. The,
we're finding out the
government's involved with him.
One of the things was selling drugs
in the Los Angeles neighborhoods,
the poor neighborhoods, and taking that
money like the CIA was selling drugs.
And our late great friend Michael
Rupert who passed away recently,
Michael Rupert,
who was a narcotics investigator for
the Los Angeles Police Department,
he uncovered that Shit. They did that. Um,
that thing where he stood out in
front of that a press conference.
They have this press conference and he,
he yells out like in,
in the middle of this conference
that he, that they, he,
he knows that the CIA has been selling
drugs in Los Angeles communities and that
he's caught them.
I mean this guy says this crazy on,
on television and the whole,
the whole crowd failed with black people.
They start cheering,
they're all excited about it and it's
like he's just standing up and like what a
fucking crazy perky was.
Yeah.
We've been following the latest,
you know what the anonymous
and the whole shooting of that
kid, the other kid in St Louis. Yeah.
That's all ugly, man. That's ugly.
The Qin Saint Louis is ugly and there
was the other kid in the Walmart that are
the fake gun. Yeah. Just like what
the fuck is going on man. You know,
there's an old expression,
but it's a really valid one.
Is that when the only tool you have is
a hammer? Everything looks like a nail.
Yeah.
And that's the problem with this
society that we have when people,
you know,
you give them guns and you put them in
situations where if they make a bad call,
someone dies. You know, if they
make a bad call, they freak out.
Someone dies.
A huge
of difference to have that they have
that on you and yeah, as an option.
But it's also like I don't know what the
options are because if you take their
guns away from them and then ask them to
enforce crime in a place where a lot of
people have guns,
boy is that even feasible?
It's like disarmament seems like the,
the choice that liked to really
cautious people would choose. Like we,
everyone needs to just give up their
guns but that's never going to happen.
Like people have to accept the fact that
there's always going to be people that
keep illegal guns if anybody
tries to do that and they'll be,
they'll be doing it with
in their mind the full
approval of the constitution.
The second day Australia,
like when they've got rid of change all
their gun laws and got rid of guns and
it was seen as it couldn't work and they
have not really had any incidents since
they've changed their downloads because
they used to be exactly the same as
America.
I don't know all the statistics on it,
but I used to be the same as American
and they had one really bad major July,
ah,
ash shooting a shoe in and um,
they changed their gun
laws as a trial thing,
I think in this particular state or area.
And it's maintained and it's worked again,
that all the same thing that people said,
you cut it,
you can't take people's guns away.
People and they did are
people protesting against it.
But then a year on kind of everyone's,
the problem is I think you trust your
government a lot more than we trust ours
because our government likes
starting wars. Yeah. Yeah.
And our government as a history
of not being honest with us,
our government has a history of
trying to suppress us. And physically,
I mean it seems for every on a yearly
basis for every huge story there is a
member of the public going
out and killing people doing,
there's then a police story of as well.
So it kind of
fuels them both. I was tweeting
that whole thing of where we are.
If we don't trust the police then we need
to be armed and then place exactly the
same as you've said, if they are police
in an area where everyone's got guns,
it's kind of,
yeah,
people need to come to an agreement
and that's not going to happen.
While it's also a problem,
when you,
whenever you have a group of people
that become sort of responsible for the
actions of an individual,
right?
If you have a hundred cops in one cop
does something really fucked up than cops
are pigs,
you know,
and all these other cops get lumped into
this one group instead of it being an
individual that was in a position of
power that did something fucked up.
It's the cops. So then it's
the cops versus the people.
Yeah. And that's madness.
You know,
it's all madness.
The Guy who shot that kid for
sure is a piece of shit. You know,
he fucked Diane. That cops in general.
Yeah. It doesn't mean, I mean I'm,
who knows what's going on
through this guy's head.
The other thing about these guys, a lot
of them have PTSD. They have like we,
you know,
you talk about PTSD for people that go
away and they fight in wars and then come
back. While a lot of those guys that
do that become cops, first of all,
when they come back,
it's a good gig for soldier.
You've already used to being in the shit.
It's probably mild in comparison
to what you've seen and you know,
I could probably handle stress
better than the average person.
It's like if you look at for a Gig,
it's probably the,
it's going to make you more comfortable
pulling your gun as well. Right.
That's true too. And you
know, you also used to,
I mean especially if
you had to have active,
you've actually been in combat and
if you've been in combat, you've,
you've definitely shot people.
If you'd definitely shop people
to be easier to shoot somebody.
Again and you also probably your senses,
your whole sense of like what's on
the line would probably be much,
much more like sharp than a person
that's never seen people killed.
Like you're right, you're like
this could happen at any second.
You better stop this before it happens.
You have like a much shorter like line of
bullshit that you'll tolerate and this,
you know, that's if you're in
a war zone as to be expected,
but that war zone becomes a streets if
you have the same attitude and your deal,
but it's just going to happen that way.
When you have people and they hate each
other and there's a group here and a
group there that comps in the citizens
and you have a situation like this,
things will be flared up for years now.
It's annoying how it has to be such a
group thing and these people against or
they use people. There was a song out
about two years ago now, it's the kind of,
just before the Trayvon
Martin stuff happened and it
was called film the police.
And it was a rewrite of Nwa funded police.
And it was just caught in everyone to,
but we've all got phones now it's
saying, right, the police are placeness,
but there's issues.
So rather than being less,
rather than being a fucked up place,
being just make sure you me filming stuff.
And it was just a huge backlash from
people in support with the police saying,
no, this isn't fair. And it's like, well,
it's not saying that film the police
and catch them all out to shit.
It's like the good ones won't be
doing anything bad. So it's not,
it's not a negative thing,
you know? But if you're,
if you're using more or watching
the watchman as it a kind of thing,
then it
starts to then police itself.
And hopefully,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with the idea of filming police. Nah.
And I think there's also a lot of evidence
that when police are forced to wear
cameras that film all their
actions, they're the, there's a,
the thing about the hemorrhoid. Yeah. The
uh, allegations of abuse dropped by 80%.
Yeah.
And someone actually said this the years
because people can't claim fake abuse.
Now, if somebody actually said
it to me on Twitter, I'm like,
or cops know that they can fucking do,
do shit because you're wearing a camera.
It's great. Again, I mean cops are people,
there's good ones and bad
ones lately in the UK.
Are you realize now that it was a time
when the cops were the best of the best,
but that's not the case anymore.
There's, there's a variation.
There's some people who are genuinely
good citizens trying to make the change,
but I knew people who,
who worked with me in the record store
and didn't get kept on and became a
policeman instead,
sorry,
you couldn't do retail and now your
police in the streets kind of illness as
crazy.
That's not as not the best of the best
that he should or was being police should
be like being the night's watch.
Yeah.
It should really be like you're
the guy whose garden, the, the,
the top of the wall. I mean, that's really
what it should be like. It's like, yeah,
she'd be a revered position of noble
people, you know, martial artists,
people who are, you know, they actually
want to do good, have a coding safe,
uh, politicians. Now,
like we all complained about how older
politicians are kind of scumbags.
It's like, cause he's not appealing job
like normal people like us wouldn't,
there's no appeal in being a fucking
politician because you're imagining how it
would be the mayor or something.
They said pip, it's your time.
It's the worst nightmare.
That shift that was like the draft.
Like you just get it drafted to be a
fucking mayor. Like out of nowhere,
we would like your lyrics. You're going
to be the mayor now. You're like, what?
And they fucking show up at
your door with accountants.
You got to go over the budget, like how
much you wanna spend on medication. What,
how much you wanna spend
on the government? What is
scratch one spend on sewage,
what span tillage? And we got a water
bill. We all Colorado, what? Yeah,
fuck all that man. And that's the problem
because everybody says fuck all that.
And the only people that don't say fuck
all that are the ones who could make
some money from it or can be or hopefully
are really dedicated to trying to help
people. You'll hope but good fucking
luck. Good luck with all that.
Especially in this day and age,
we're going to need some
dust to settle the semester.
I mean it's just with the whole
politics thing you need to know,
I kind of argue with people on online
about this all the time because I think
the way your democracy is currently set
up and that the democracy is currently
set up,
there's no chance of any real change
like anytime soon because it's a gradual,
it's slight changes either way,
but nothing else is discussed.
We need to protect the ideals of
democracy and it's like, well,
why? Yeah, I think
there's, I mean there's,
I'm going completely
off on tangent nowadays.
There's hundreds of different kinds of
ocracy kinds of ways to run a society.
Number one add democracies
we've got aren't real
democracies, right? They kind of,
it's the two party system and all
this coming. So it's not a real,
we just vote and that's who gets in and
they're often being funded by the same
company. Exactly. It's the
same. Incredibly ridiculous.
And there's loads of,
I mean I was just discussing recently
and it pisses people off because it kind
of shows a level of elite isn't
that people are scared of,
but I think going on stuff based on,
on a Marriott,
Chrissy and stuff like that where say
your vote would be worth more than the guy
who,
who is sitting at home in a trailer and
doesn't know anything about politics.
But that good though that's kind of
dangerous from one person's vote is worth
more than another. It's, it's
measured. So for example,
my theory on it being if when you go to
vote there's a short questionnaire on
politics or on social
on society or something.
And that ranks or what you wear, but isn't
that subjective? I mean, first of all,
there's just information like you
could have information about politics.
That's one thing. Like you know,
when was Eleanor Roosevelt,
this one was on policies,
on policies and and what's what's
actually valid at the moment.
Because then even if people than just
bone up on it to try and cheat the system.
That's good. They're reading
about what the policies are.
They learning it rather than just going
and taking the box that they're family
have always supported Republicans.
Therefore that's that.
That's forcing people to have some level
of education in it to make their vote
worth more.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm hanging on to the idea that
everyone should have an equal vote and
that it shouldn't be like an earned thing
and you earn it by having an education
about the system.
And there's a great quote,
great quote that says we're not
all entitled to our own opinion.
We're all into our auto, our own informed
opinion. Because again, everyone quotes,
I think I'm entitled to
my opinion said, well, no.
If someone's done more research
on it and knows about it,
then there's, there is right and
wrong. You can't just say, okay,
well in my opinion I'm entitled
to it. On a lionfish is, yeah,
there's some issues where it's not.
There's some issues where it's
just a subjective judgment.
One person would agree,
one person would disagree,
like there's certain issues
that people are very,
very passionate about that you have polar
opposite people absolutely dedicated
to their opinion and won't budge. Yeah,
like abortion, that's a great thing,
but then it's an informed
opinion is not just a kind of,
sometimes not even though sometimes
there's not an informed opinion.
Sometimes people just get on
a side and that's their side.
Stuck on that side can get crazy,
but that's people.
That's a super common thing.
Like take on republican talking points
or take on liberal talking points.
Really Common or oh,
the bibles that,
the key example of that where people
are just blindly, we'll vast fast.
That's my belief and therefore I will
fight any arguments against it despite any
logic and theories and yeah, in
reality. Yeah, that's a big one.
That's a common one because you know,
that's one
that has been used for so many years for
so many people and it's become just a
oh well paved path that
everybody could walk on.
It's a great structure and set
up our first song that, um,
got vehicle at when I was working with
regard done a sac was called are always
Kale when it was just a
rewrite of commandments.
It was a load of commandments for now.
And I'm not religious,
but the reason I think it hit through
with people is this a simple structure
that you all know and are familiar with,
but,
and that's why it works for religion as
well as in a spoken word hip hop song.
It's kind of is that simplicity of, you
know, the stories and the structures,
therefore you can get a point
across that isn't about religion,
but by using those,
that's more about society and people,
but using that template of what
religious people have laid down for us.
Yeah.
What religious people of rate laid down
and you know the variance in like how
much they vary from one to the next.
Like how much Judaism varies from Islam.
Various can Christianity,
how much they borrow from each other.
Like some of these wrong,
somebody's wrong.
Well let's just break down like
what you guys are actually what,
what are we supporting here?
And we supporting the idea that there
is a guy and this guy watches over
everything and he made everything.
He's allowing all this crazy chaos and
he told us once a few thousand years ago
how to live your life.
And if you don't pay attention to
what the fuck he said back then,
you're on your own. And so you're
forced to be led by a bunch of people.
He sees these people, he sees they're
hypocritical actions, he does nothing.
He allows them to distort his message
and relay it in its most fucked up way.
That's ruining the earth itself.
And still,
he doesn't come down and correct anybody
like this is what you're saying. Yeah.
That's crazy.
Are you sure?
Or is this puzzle far too
complex for our brains?
Is this like an ant trying
to understand a satellite?
Because if you try to get an
aunt to understand a satellite,
it's outside of his realm
of comprehension lately.
And I think we have a realm
of comprehension, whether
we like to admit it or not.
And I think the very nature
of the universe itself is
currently outside of our
realm of comprehension,
or at least the realm of comprehension
of the average person. Me included.
Phife has gotta be the most
dangerous word ever made. But that's,
that's the thing that the argument
would, where do I say, well, you know,
we were left here and we've got to have
faith that God's going to do this and do
that. And it's all, all
tests. But I've got my faith.
It's like that's a massive get out clause
for any argument of, well, we've never,
you can't see this person. You can't
prove. And it not only can not prove it,
but you're having faith in something
that looks very much like bullshit.
Yeah. You know, if you look the stories
you read, the guy came back from the dead,
he was dead for three days and then he
pushed her rock side and came back. Okay.
Oh yeah. All right. I believe
that. Okay, this is Adam and Eve's.
There's two people and then
they fucked and what happens?
They have kids and then time
though, right? Kids accepted.
Cause everyone kind of jokes now
and mocks Scientology cause of the
ludicrousness of loads of, of what they
say. But it's ludicrous because it's new.
If it was thousands of years old,
then people would be the same with
Christianity and just kind of go, well,
you know,
it is kind of ludicrous,
but [inaudible] Christianity's ludicrous.
Yeah.
Have you have conversations with
hardcore Christians about whether or not
Christianity's ludicrous know, argue
with you while why it's not? Yeah,
and what the story's really represent
and how the message of God comes through
these stories. Like I think
he's crazy, but there's,
there's such a mixture as well in there.
The study will be loads
of questions that no,
that all that stuff is kind of bullshit,
but they believe what they believe
and they believe their genomic,
that they are just stories and all this
kind of thing. So it's, well there's also,
he's a levels within
your own belief system.
There's such a variation as people who
would sit here now and go yam if less
fucking crazy.
But that devout Christians and yeah,
there's people that just believe in God
and they feel like the Bible is sort of
a framework for good behavior that was
laid down by this holy entity at one
point in the past.
And that although the stories had been
twisted and weird and you know that a lot
of these stories,
they probably represented something,
something important a long time ago.
And so you're getting these,
this connection to God like through a
game of me in that game of telephone or if
you played it in England but you,
you would tell a friend something and
then he would tell friends something that
he would tell friends.
By the time it got down to Brian,
I can tell you the story was dog shit.
It was all fucked up.
And I think that the idea is that in
the UK it was called Chinese whispers,
which sounds incredibly racist,
but that's what it was.
It was called Chinese whispers.
It wasn't,
that's that game anyway at telephone is
a far better name for it and let's stick
with that.
But that whole idea is that at the end
of that is God at the end of that has god
and yeah, the story got mucked up,
but the, the story did get fucked up.
But that story has a
direct connection to God.
And the way that grunt direct connection
works is that at one point in time
there was,
there was something where someone was
explained the very nature of the universe
and then whether it's
through psychedelic drugs,
whether it was through an actual
religious experience with a divine entity.
And then from that point, what happened
is that person told another person,
that person told another person they did
their best to remember everything that
the people before them told them. But
if you got through all that goofy Shit,
all that Adam and eve stuff and all
that fucking, although the, the,
the more weird and ridiculous and
preposterous stories in any religion,
if you got through all that
and went back to the source,
you almost are still connected
in some sort of a weird,
bizarre and maybe like a,
um,
like an all like almost like
a mathematical way you're
connected to the original
story. Yeah. You know, the, his original
story, the original story turns
into this, his memory fucks it up.
It turns into that. Like, is
it correct at the end? Yeah,
no translations as well though.
The trend line is,
was all written in a language that is
dead and people to very trans language,
things like that. And it's like, whoa.
Well there's two of them too far away from
does the,
the oldest version that they found is the
stuff that's in Qumran that's the Dead
Sea Scrolls. Yeah. Though the, some of
the same stores that are in the Bible,
so these are the oldest versions
by like a thousand years.
And I think they're the only
ones that are in Aramaic.
It's an Aramaic and it's written on
animal skins. Yeah, it's fucking crazy.
They piece together to Dead
Sea scrolls with and a,
they made sure that they got the DNA of
the same cow so they knew if this the
same cow,
it most likely was the same piece of
paper because they were all different
counties and different pieces of paper
and they had to figure out like which,
which animal skins cause all these crumbs
and pieces and they had a piece them
together over decades.
Man. Just, it's craziness.
Madness and that is what all the
faith and belief so based on,
and they just really in this shit man,
it wasn't like
1947 again, there's that old, I think
it was in a TV series in the UK.
There was as a joke thing,
have they found the original first
page of the Bible just saying that um,
any resemblance to people in real life
is purely coincidental and so on and so
forth from that. It's just a book
of fiction and some found out thing.
Yeah. In my, the best
version of the world.
It would be that you get to the end
of the Bible and it just says psych.
We were on mushrooms.
That would be the best version
before bear left. David Copperfield.
I ate it all up.
Yeah.
1946 I collection of 981
texts was discovered,
uh,
between 46 and 56 took some 10 years in
this area in the West Bank called Qumran
and they were found inside caves about
a mile inland north of the North West
shore of the Dead Sea and
really interesting shit, man.
Nine or the scrolls were rediscovered
at the Israeli antiquities authority in
2014 after they'd had been stored
unopened for six decades following their
excavation in 1952 the texts
are of great historical,
religious and linguistic significance
because they include the earliest known
surviving manuscripts of works later
included in the Hebrew Bible Canon along
with due to rada bow doodle raw cononical
Deuteronomy due to Ra Deuteronomy.
Me
Too.
Sure. Oh, you know, this is how like my
wife is saying this to me the other day.
It's interesting when you're raising
kids and you're teaching them how to say
words and you know you have to spell it
and you, you see how it's difficult. Well,
when you learn a new word like this,
like you know Deuteronomy,
I could just say it and it would be easy,
but I'm trying to figure it out
as I'm saying like a little kid,
like that's kind of never
goes away due to row.
Can Non Nicole do the row canonical
and extra biblical manuscripts which
preserve the evidence of the diversity
of religious thought in the late Second
Temple Judaism. Interesting.
Interesting. Interesting stuff man. Yeah.
From 408 BCE and 318 BCE.
Man,
they don't really know though.
It's crazy that it's just that the barbell
is just a collection of stories and
not one Johnny wasn't written
as one thing. You kind of
think of it as the Bible,
but sign that pops of the stuff on the,
on the Dead Sea scrolls were
stories included in the Bible.
Yeah. Yes. Just pick 400 shoes. Bce.
Wonder what the oldest known. That's
the, um, the old, that's the range. The,
so the oldest one,
they found 400 APC.
I wonder what the oldest version of the
Hebrew Bible is. If you had to guess
40 years, shut up, bitch. This
ridiculous. What do you think?
Like the oldest version of the
Hebrew Bible clue 3000 years.
Cause I,
I'm at assumed that actually the Dead
Sea scrolls were from earlier than that.
I'd read some something that must've
been incorrect that said it was a older
than that. Okay. The oldest
surviving Hebrew manuscript,
including the Dead Sea Scrolls,
second century BCE. Well,
this is a gift Wikipedia and it's given
me a different date because they were
saying for like four oh eight.
Right? Was that what the uh, the,
the longest version. Uh, so
that is like the oldest version.
That's the oldest version of the Hebrew
Bible or the oldest oldest version of
the stories that are in
the habit. Yeah. Amazing.
Imagine if you can go back to those dudes
who wrote the Bible way back then and
you could bring them in a time machine
to 2014 and show them like they're the
havoc that they've created.
Have them explain. Yeah.
What was that makes the whole page out
there that had been tweak it a little?
Well, it's so weird that it's, it gets
translated into different languages.
Like have you ever done one
of those things where you
take Russian and translate
it to English and you try to like
explain what the fuck they mean?
Their language is so different than ours
that it always comes out like he gives
to country but fails not yet.
You know,
there's like, there's a
weird weird interpretation
of, of languages to English.
So you gotta think you're going from
a weird language like ancient Hebrew,
which was, um, the, these
to have, like their numbers
were embedded in their words.
So like there was no,
there's no number.
What if it just started off as means?
Like whatever.
Just going back to how the Bible,
you know,
the language back then
actually was just like,
we all talk like a mean back
then like I like you just said,
that sounds like a meme.
Almost like I go back home knee,
I'm saying no, no, no, no,
that's not the Bible. You know,
you're paying attention when I said
that's like if you take Russian and
interpreted to English. Right. That's
not what I'm saying. Um, the, the,
the um, just the ancient
languages, like when they try that,
I've got that translation and the original
thing they read in is just so old and
they're using DNA to kind of pace in the
right order and all that kind of thing.
It's mostly guessing, right? Well, no,
not really guessing, you know, I mean,
these fit,
there's definitely pieces missing,
but when they have stories that are like,
when they translate,
part of the story in the story is like
very similar to like book of Genesis or
something along those lines.
They could sort of make those correlations
if they have enough similarities.
But there's a lot of those
stories that are like, that man.
Like that when you go
back to the oldest shit,
that cuneiform that the
Sumerians used to write in. Oh,
it's so weird looking man.
It's like these, these there,
there was no like variation in the,
like the way their letters were,
the letters were all
like these little wines.
So they'd go down to like pull this
up like cuneiform ancients who?
Marion. It's weird, weird shit man.
They would write in this Google
search his head. Same place. Yeah.
It's um, it's cool just right.
Yeah. It's like, it would,
it looks like is like a wedge that you
would like to say with your trauma down a
trade at a stick. A wedge and
they're like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like they're more like wedges than they
are. Like, it's not like a straight line.
It's like there's a fat top and then it
goes down to a lower bottom and they say
this is how they wrote. Like look at
these things. How weird is that? Yeah,
it's like all I know Jay's,
yeah, it's so, it's so weird.
I mean it's sort of like,
um,
it's so hard to imagine
how different that is.
Keep that up so we could look at that
shit for a second. Look how weird that is.
Like that's the language and they write
these little columns and so much of it
just just to us look in exactly the
same look as similar shapes and sizes.
Hacking that of the intricacies of,
of a language. Yeah. If he's like,
if you looked at that,
that looks like dog shit.
Like if you had your whole life to
figure out what the fuck that means.
Good luck. He was never figure it
out. You'd never figure it out.
So it takes like a team of linguists
to pieces together and here's the crazy
shit. They don't even know
what the word sounded like.
Like there's a bunch of words in ancient
Sumerians fucking guesswork. There was,
there was a thing that someone had done
a where they had a recreated what they
believe ancient Sumerian sounded like,
but it's so dead that no one can
even talk it. Yeah, of course.
Like how can you even start
to see you how to pronounce
the scratch ins that were on
that thing then? So weird. Well,
I don't know how they do it.
I don't know.
I know that they have like this is what
it looked like. This is the language.
Yeah, I guess some of them,
oh, this is year by year.
Will escrow make that a little larger
so it gets hit as a year by year.
Like let's scroll down so you can get
to the top, to the top, to the top.
We'll see 3,200 BC,
3000 BCE,
and then you go all the way to the far
right and it's just all the lines are
thousand. Yeah. Wow.
Those weird lines, man.
That's interesting. So this was like
eight bit and this is like Xbox. They,
they pretty much updated it to a better
language. Have you ever white round?
Oh, other way, Ramey, right,
right. Yeah. Yeah. Well let's go.
I'll be be partly down to the,
the methods in which they were brought in.
If,
if they couldn't have done more intricate
stuff. If you're, you're scratching into
clay,
into clay and stuff like that.
They also would make these rollers that
would make these rollers and then they
would lay out clay.
And they would roll the roller into
the clay and then baked the clay.
So like the roller itself would be
like a method of distributing like a
newspaper.
Like you'd be able to roll that shit
and he'd put it in the clay and then you
could do several times. Yeah. Yeah.
So they had these weird things they
used to do to make these clay tablets.
So you kind of have to make the newspaper
yourself. Yes, I wear a gas. I mean,
I can remember hearing is,
it's crazy.
The first the first adverts ever made were
musical notes and that printed on the
product you bought and you had to sing the
advert yourselves as the
first ever jingles Rhea
cigarette pack per pack packets
and that. But in those
days, um, because yeah,
there wasn't any radio and
stuff like that and it,
in those days everyone kind of had a piano
or could, could, could play his shit.
And yeah, the first ever, uh,
jingles were printed and written out and
people would sit around the piano and
play the,
the camel cigars.
Wow. That's wild. What origin of Jingles,
which is the original jingles was
advertising. Hey, pull up, uh,
Sumerian cylinder seals and you could
see these things they used to do where
they used to lay this clay down and
roll their message out onto the clay.
And I guess like if you probably
wanted to get a message to somebody,
you would send a seal, you send one
of these cylinders and then you, yeah,
they would lay the clay out and they
would roll a cylinder on the clay and it
would read out what you had
to say to them and that wild,
what would you think this says?
Like, Hey, those are the bird. Well,
I think they range in a meeting
that represents UFO was Brian,
don't you get it? Look at the Griffin and
the bottom UFO. That's an alien. The sea,
those squirrely things.
That's DNA.
So what that represents is the alien
came down from sky and Leo's rule and the
griffins are awesome bird
looking freaky lion things.
And what of those lines on the top?
It's like a male lion and a female
lines that what's going on there?
Yeah. They're like high fiving what
they're doing knuckles. So it looks like
this is the number one
culture that the uh,
ancient astronauts theorists point too.
They love this stuff because it was so
far ago. You like, who fucking knows?
It's so long ago who the fuck
knows what was really going on?
But these people in ancient Sumeria,
they had all this like,
like they were really into stars. They
had all these um, images of like the, uh,
the galaxy.
They had a,
a depiction of the solar system with all
the stars are all the planets rather in
the correct orbit. It's really
interesting. Yeah. Pull up a Sumerian,
um, solar system. Ancient
Samarian solar system.
Is that horses having sex?
It's one goat looking when we,
when go look the other way in some
crazy thing in the middle going,
what do you want from me?
Everybody's banging everybody's name
and put your message to about to send.
We need to commit this cylinder.
And you can get the word out about the
way that that goat was looking. Well,
it's like today,
have you ever made a note on your phone?
And you couldn't remember what the fuck
mad like at the time. You like,
I'll understand this so many times.
Or waking up at night and thinking
I've got a lyric or an idea,
just note in it and they're
looking at it going, what the,
what is it that you wanted?
Um, Sumerian solar system.
Yeah. Yeah. There's a,
there's an image of the sun in the
center and all these planets that are
floating around the sun and they're all
in like the sort of a similar sizes.
Like see, see how it's like that.
Similar to what the actual planets are.
That's what it looked like in the, but
pull it back. So you actually see the,
the image of itself,
the actual a cylinder image.
You just had it. Oh yeah, you can see it.
No, the image, the actual image of the,
there's a clay image of it. See It on the
right. That's it. Either one of those.
That's the actual image. And if you
see the op, see that right there.
That's the solar system in between them.
There's the sun and those circles.
Those are the exact planets.
And you know,
the bigger ones are bigger and the small
ones are smaller and they're all in the
right orbit. It's really weird.
Yes. Way. Most likely the standard,
what they think is,
you know,
when I've listened to many people give
their opinions on these kinds of things
and how do these people know
what they knew and what I, I'm,
I'm have an opinion that most likely
at one point in time people were really
fucking smart and they had gotten really
far and they had learned a lot of shit
and they had lived for a long time
and then cataclysmic happened.
They get hit by asteroids, they got
hit by, you know, super volcanoes,
whatever it is.
And whatever was learned was forgotten
and they started all over again.
And he probably did it a gang of times
and paper to kind of argue against that.
We'll say just that,
yeah, would they have fly?
Why aren't there cameras over or whatever.
But I think the very nature of the,
of that theory is there's no chance at
all that their intelligence would have
developed in the same way
as did the technology.
Wouldn't have developed in the same way.
They could've been far superior yet.
Never invented petrol or use
electronics tonics, any of that.
So that kind of, yeah, it makes sense
of, it's our own arrogance now of going,
but you know, they didn't have
TV so I can't be that clip.
I how they clever that I can go to.
So true.
It's so, that's such a
good point. And you know,
I think that people from England have a
bit of a better perspective of time than
people in America because if you're
in London, if you go through London,
you'll see thousand year old buildings.
Like you don't see that shit in America.
A wedding in Boston once,
and I had a dice burn up,
popped into an antique
store and it was like,
oh by the fifties and
sixties and it's like,
that's not an antique store
had to England antiques.
There's like hundreds of years old or
this old stuff for theirs. I, yeah,
this is antiques. This
is like ies. This is,
this is a long time ago. It's like, no,
that's not, that's not what Atlantic,
here's my friend. Yeah. There's bars in
London that are like a thousand years old,
right? Yeah. That's so crazy. The
whole place is, it's so different.
Like when you're passing by the
palace and you look at that thing,
you see Buckingham Palace and you're
like, well that that, that's a palace.
It's right here.
They have a pallet and then it's another
thing in Nis went driving around.
I see a lot of the houses that are
kind of castle like and they think that
that's what a carceral looks
like. It's like, have you been,
have you been to a castle
because castles aren't really,
causes aren't just houses.
We have a little square bit on top is
that there are these built out or rocks
and these huge things and you're always
entertains me over here. The, yeah,
all the different castles is like this.
Isn't it weird that they sell castles?
Like you can buy a castle?
Yeah. Like you screw bees.
Pip could go back to England
and by a Goddamn castle.
I want to counsel now who do I need
to talk to about this? Joe Broken.
I don't know.
We need to find the guy.
And connect you to him because I've
watched some one of those home and garden
shows, you know when they're like people
work on how you a car so or you buy on a
regional and old.
They had an old castle.
They were trying to do an addition.
Yeah,
add ons to the castle and they had
a fight like tooth and claw to get,
they wanted to like put a garage on or
something like that and like fuck off,
you can't, it's a castle. But
he's like, it's my castle.
I'm like, nope, can't do it.
Until they eventually let him do they
want to topic a clicker for the drawbridge
site. When they pull
off, I can just come on.
He'll be out like an RFID card.
They put in your license plate soon as
it recognizes your driving and opens up
the drawbridge. No one else
can get in. There's loading.
There's a few different
costumes and England that
hotels now and you can just go
and stay in a castle that is hundreds
and hundreds of years old. I've,
I've done that before and it's, yeah.
Yeah. Imagine owning. You can though.
I know people have,
I've heard of people that are famous.
People like by castle feel so
rude to put a TV and everything.
Even though later in this I would
cast on your leg kicking it out. Yeah.
You should uneven like it really probably
shouldn't even have electricity. Nah,
you want to do exams? Everything
should be candlelight. Yeah.
If you're going to do it right. I mean
that's where England basically like,
anyway, it's all holding candle there.
I know. That's right. Is it really?
That's the image that we give out.
Check this out.
You can get some castles right
here. Kind of cancer. Video Castles.
Yeah. What kind of castle?
What do you mean? It's like
a, like, like a website? Yeah,
it's all cal state website.
I know one of them says the castle's
a thousand pounds a million.
Is that a million pounds? But it says
what's a pound as it relates to a dollar.
Right at the moment the adult is,
so that'd be about
1.8 million.
So 1 million pounds is 1.8 million deaths.
Pretty good deal for a castle.
Yeah. That seemed, it seemed crazy.
It seems like castles or one of those
things that really wouldn't appreciate
very much. They don't probably worth
castle in Transylvania after it.
Well yeah. And it doesn't come
with a vampire fuck that 47.
Do you want to have a castle? Where
do you, what do you weekend? Oh,
we go to Transylvania.
We have a summer home.
Wifi would suck in a castle.
Nonexistent.
You probably would have to have
satellite Internet. I mean,
you might not even be able to get that.
I guarantee you they haven't laid the
lines down unless this castle has been
used by people for a long time.
Alright. Uh, drove fruit,
a trans surveying you on our last tour
and it just feels like the most underused.
Like
they should put a Dracula Disneyland
or some shit there. Yeah, right.
It'd be the most,
that'd be a huge tourist.
And you go through and here's eerie and
kind of run down and really no economy
going on there and you just think
this is Transylvania for fuck's sake.
Surely that's the most surely asked,
most marketable real location.
Like most people's mind to find
out that that's a real place.
That's not just a fictional
thing in a book. It's like this.
They've got someone needs to go
there and build a tourist results.
You should do it. You should do it.
You should contact a tourism board,
a remortgage my castle and I like,
I'll see if I can can
open up Transylvania.
But doesn't it seem like that would
be like a dope idea? Yeah. No.
And you think of loads of kind of
what are way you have these um,
amusement parks and things like that.
It's normally in kind of shady areas
where there isn't anything else anyway
cause you don't want that
in the middle of a town.
They'll say that about Anaheim sir.
Exactly. That chance rude Orlando either.
But it makes them a
destination and oh yeah.
Orlando used to big time
destination just because of those.
And if you like what kind of like
if you had, Whoa, how about this?
If you had a fucking spot where you had,
it was like a amusement park,
but it was all horror rides.
Everything was fucking terrifying.
Like they're doing an
American Werewolf in London,
Mays at universal for a Halloween,
which I'll be attending every day.
See that shit that's going
to be fun did on mushrooms.
But could you imagine that amusement park,
purely fat outs.
Amusement Park for adults in Transylvania.
That's all Har. And then they set up,
they set up the entire location.
Like they have like fucking
like speakers in the woods.
We hear like horrible in the middle
of the night while you're sleeping.
They scared the fucking shit out of you.
Everywhere you go.
Like people are a, instead of like,
you know when you go to Disneyland,
you see dudes are dressed up like fucking,
you know,
Mickey Mouse and goofy and you go
by goofy's kitchen and goofy wavy.
Instead of that, you have dudes
made up and like full har outfits.
I'm terrified of working
this out of nowhere.
Just had to know where they dive in.
Funny [inaudible] and then take
off into the bushes. They don't.
They don't fuck with people. They don't
hit them, but they scare the shit out of,
I guess when you're going there though,
you'd have to sign so much shit to say.
You're not going to punch anyone.
Oh, was it? Someone jumps out. Yeah,
and this is something,
I think this is like a camp where you
go camping and it's pets a horror camp.
Oh Great. There's no, it sounds
like a recipe for murder.
It's probably really annoying.
Well,
if you were like a crazy fucking wanted
to kill people, like Jason Style,
wouldn't you want to do it at this
camp? It seemed so appropriate. Yeah.
[inaudible] in the UK now where they have
kind of these Zombie two things or web
and it'll be in an old shopping center
or something that you'll pay to go and be
part of it and it will be all act.
Just kind of just jumping in and chase
and you were zombies and you'll be, yeah.
Living out the Zombie
apocalypse. Yeah. Again,
all of that just feels how many of
those actors get punched in the face or,
or someone just reacting
in panic and her in people.
What they really need to
do is make real zombies.
I mean like artificial
real Zombie have like,
well you do is you make like a Mike to
day a person that's not really a person.
So now we are person.
It's dead.
He showed Scott it's shriveled up brand
but it can move and it comes at you like
it's going to bite you and you have a
sword and there's like hundreds of them
and it's like a new amusement park.
And this is when bioengineering
gets to like a really high level.
Like you know it's been said a
million times, but the phone,
the process of that you have
in your phone was far greater.
It's far greater than the processes of
put people on the fucking moon. Yeah.
Right. Okay. So imagine what kind
of technology they're having today.
They're starting to develop
all these artificial cells.
They can artificial skin,
they're going to develop
artificial body parts.
It's going to get to a point where about
thousand years from now you're going to
be able to make zombies and
know everyone's gonna know
it doesn't have a soul.
You can just chop this fucker up.
I be carrying as a Zombie donor card
to say that we're not die. Definitely.
I want just turn me into a Zombie,
but I'm saying artificial
many fly free access to it.
People are never gonna
allow that and see that's,
that's the difference what you're talking
about as an actual person that becomes
a Zombie.
So complete.
I'm talking about as a constructed
artificial person that never had the
potential to be an actual
person. It's made entirely. Yeah.
You know factory that
has no soul whatsoever,
but it's made out of an artificial flesh
with bones and moves at you and it's
trying to buy you out on what do you do?
You fucking sword fight this bit on the
note book of people who are working on
making clones and share.
How far down do you think clothing our
official zombies is? All that shit shorty.
They're first going to be
looking at a lot of my teachers,
especially my more
poorly thought out ones,
a lot of them require like some sort of
a demise of civilization for them to be
valid, and this is one of them. We would
have to have some serious casualties.
We'd have to devalue life
in a way where like today,
as as the answer that when people are
against cloning the dangers of it and
they're not a real person and the risks
of playing God, it's like, well, no,
there's zombies.
We're only going to make them.
We're not going to have them thinking
and acting with just clonings all right,
as long as we make him brain
dead zombies essentially. Well,
if we really just decided to start
cloning people, that would be,
that would be a huge issue.
Could you imagine if people just decided
they wanted to make more scrupulous
pips?
Yeah.
What if they got ahold of your DNA and
it made a bunch of them and you didn't
even realize that they did that until
they were like 15 or 16 then you made them
and you're an older man and you're meeting
yourself at 15 there's like 20 of you
and you're like,
what the fuck?
I'm not even responsible for my own self
growing up and the come in there to to
wipe you out and they're using your name
or that can be out and you want to use
Rogan's a ton of Giotto pops Cosby.
Y'All look exactly like you
all have your fingerprint.
Is that what the Real Rick
Ross Ross thing? It actually
is. Is it a clone thing?
No,
they don't know where to like at all.
The Real Rick Ross is actually quite lean.
Cut Them.
The fake Rick Ross is the one that's,
if cloning came about and you had
the choice of doing it yourself,
would that be of any,
why would I want to clone myself but I
don't see how I'd benefit from that just
made me,
I don't get it.
If it's not about surely you'd
have the rights to your own day.
And I logically that be a key
thing rather than me finding out,
I'm bumping into scripts where it
would have to be, I would have,
you would find out that when
you signed your terms of use,
when you got your iPhone that you gave
up your right to clone yourself and that
they already knew. Yeah. So every
time you like use your phone,
a little bit of your DNA gets in you
from your ear, wax gets into the speaker,
then you turn them in and
then it's make copies of you.
That'd be some scam that to
expose on CNN or something.
If they're making iPhones that take an
iPhone's then using those DNA collectors.
Yeah, they're making copies
of screws. Pep. Well,
I think we're going to wonder at one point
in time we're going to wonder what is
it acceptable way to
consider how to engineer,
um, our civilization, both like
as our society, like how we have,
how we govern ourselves, how we
have laws, how we distribute money.
And then also like how we breed.
Like there's gonna come a point in
time when people become like super,
super intelligent,
far removed from this weird sort of
ape like situation we find ourselves in
today. And if they get to that
0.1 day they'd be like, look,
how much should we be investing our
intellectual time into actively breeding
people the way we do every other
animal that we have under our control.
I mean the way we breed
cows,
the way we breed dogs,
the way should we just keep doing this
whole thing on love or should we just
love everybody and breed according to the
best way possible to enhance the human
race?
Is that but surely that in turn just
involve calming down breathing hugely.
Because surely the biggest problem of
the human race is that there's far too
many of us to fit on this.
That's true.
Planet would that boiling pot
of having far too many of us,
it's like it sort of highlights the
reason why that would be a terrible idea
because there's so many variables that
make society awesome and all of them come
from completely different realities.
Like the variable of the computer geek
is a very different reality than the
variable of a pro football player,
which is,
and all these variables like
in biological variables too,
like as far as like the
way your body works,
it might lead you in one direction or
another, like relieved your desires.
And that's what makes this whole world
so fucking cool and crazy in the first
place.
So could you imagine if we got so
far advanced that we decided to start
genetically engineer and go straight
away rather than everything that can
influence and, and yeah. And in
doing so, we lost all art. Yeah.
We lost all of it because
it's not functional and well,
because everybody's perfect. Everyone's
perfect. No one has any emotions.
Everyone's rational and logical.
There's no more art. It's over.
We're super advanced, no. On our
and those strippers, this kid,
well, we'd have robots copers and then we
would slowly start to evolve and people
enjoyed robot strippers and
one, they invoice involved, uh,
and enjoyed meditation classes,
memory injection that they're not real.
You just have like a Netflix
of like memories. Like, oh,
I just fuck that stripper.
Well,
I think there's definitely going to be
a time where you're going to be able to
download memories. I think that's,
I think that is without a doubt,
what we're seeing with these
Google glasses. What you're
seeing is the beginning.
Like you could take photos
with Google glass, right? Yeah.
You could look at things,
you can take photos. Well,
if you can look at things and take photos,
what are you doing when you're taking
a photo, you're capturing time,
you're capturing a moment.
It's just not the best version of it,
but it's way better than a painting
they use to capture type of thing that's
here now and pulling it into. Exactly,
exactly. But it's very two dimensional.
It's right in front of you.
Well,
it'll eventually become three dimensional
and then one day it'll be immersive.
One day you'll be able to record and not
just record a single image. Like we're,
this is the baby steps. One day, you know,
this is like when people started at first
started figuring out if fire, you know,
and that what that led to is
the combustion engine. I mean,
think about that all the way up to
plane travel. It was figuring out fire.
All that other shit comes up after it.
Yeah.
Well we're seeing now by being able
to take a photograph with the glasses.
We're capturing time in a very rudimentary
way, but really for us, amazing. Yeah.
Well one day we're going to be able
to capture everything about it.
The way your seat feels, the
way your hands are sweaty,
the way your beard itches,
the way your clothes fit.
You're going to be in that life.
So you'll be able to take someone's
memory and just run an a whatever it is,
you know, an hour program
to our program. You know,
people will be able to
upload their sexual exploits.
You mean that's going to be loaded?
Yeah. We should remove the point
of need in a memory as such,
because if you can just
access it all in Armenia,
it didn't kill our ability to actually
remember stuff cause you don't need to
ensure the same as how Google already
and now there's so much that you don't
need to learn or take in because you can
really quickly see who was in that film
and who and what else he was
saying. There's that kind
of instant things. So, yeah,
absolutely. I think the first thing
that's going to happen is there,
there's going to be a search of your
memory starting from a certain period of
time where you're going
to be able to access, uh,
like what you had said in
the past or did in the past.
And it's going to be more searchable.
Like to the point where I go,
what did I say last night around 10
o'clock you said at 10 oh one blah, blah,
blah, while standing at this location.
And you know what I mean? Like it's right,
right, right. Yeah.
You're going to have Google for yourself
and that's why you'll be able to ask it.
Yeah. What you did and you'd be able to
pull it up of ruin the fun of arguments
though. Truly when you can accurately
say, now here's what you actually said.
This isn't rather than, no, no, no,
no. I didn't say, I never said that.
I meant what I said was this, Nah, let's,
where are you on the next
logical progression, right?
Because it's Google's already,
yeah.
Ruined the bullshitters argument when
people bullshit about stuff. You Go,
wait a minute, let me go
over that. It's not true.
Like how many of those conversations have
happened since Google where those guys
would have been insufferable.
Fox forever
playlists. Weird. I've always enjoyed
in, in, in football or soccer. Um,
as, as you guys insist on calling it, um,
we don't insist on calling it anything.
We wish it would go away.
Follow pop.
These white people in America would
stop attending. They like soccer to be,
to appear more interesting.
Hipsters fuck off.
For years they were pushing for
goal line technology and all this.
Just see if it go will definitely happen.
All right. The main guy in charge.
He's argument for not having it was a one.
The best things about this
sport is arguing over that
shit and I loved that as a
kind of best.
That's the best logical reason I've heard
that it's better not knowing exactly
like referees decision and
then the next day you're like,
that clearly went over the line.
This is, Yup. That's great.
That's part of sport that that's
a big thing. I've been perfect.
And baseball,
it's so boring.
But they love to argue when someone safe
or out and they'll fucking play that
foot touching that bag a hundred times
and the guy catching the ball and the
foot touching the bag and he got,
yeah,
they'll play this shit over
and over and over again.
That's a terrible call by the referee.
I disagree from my point of view. I
think it was the right call Nola. Geez.
Just saying, no, here's the Ariosa.
That's it. That was out. It's exactly,
it takes all the fun out of it takes
a little bit of the fun out of it.
Especially goofy sports, goofy
sports, you know? It's just like
it's a, it's a strange thing our obsession
with, with the scoring, you know,
I mean it's really kind of,
we have a built in need for war and a
built in need to conquer and built a need
to form tribes to go
on after other tribes.
We figured out a way to do it
peaceably your support. Yeah. You know,
through organized high
level athletic competitions.
We have our team takes on your team and
if we win we drank and we run to the
streets.
Woo Shit.
It's freaking has,
is that an intentional thing in sports?
Like I mean in MMA everyone talks about
is the 10 point must system the right
system during this an
active thing of well yeah,
cause everyone's having this discussion
and talking about it and engage in about
this fire rather than are,
you know,
it'd be best if we actually
knew who won and who.
The problem with that is sometimes
the scoring system is so bad and so
ineffective that it leaves everyone
feeling like they got robbed. Yeah.
And you see our thing is I
think the scoring system works.
It's just you need better understanding
from the judges and from the,
from all of that. I think
again, almost any system,
if it's clear enough and
the people understand it,
then I agree with you in some ways.
But I um, I also think that it's
just not a comprehensive enough, um,
system to have 10 points. Yeah.
Because MMA is not one sport.
See if it's boxing thing about boxing
is did this guy uses hands better or did
that guy use his hands better? Yeah, this
guy did well then. Then he went and look,
we got, he scored a hundred,
you know, punches he five,
you know them where this and 10 were
that and 30 with any, you go over these,
these statistics and it's kind of
clear who one who got the round.
It's not hard to pick her out.
But when you start factoring in things
like take downs and then things like leg
kicks and things like submission attempts
and you have a quantify what's more
important, whether it's the strike or
the takedown, what's more important?
Is it more important this guy landed five
punches or is more important than that
guy took the other guy down and held
onto him and did nothing and different
people are gonna have different opinions.
It's very subjective.
And when you're dealing with
something like that 10 point system,
one guy's going to get 10, one guy's
going to get nine. Like it's very screwy.
It's, you need more, you need, you
need like a scoring for Graham grain.
They're really Arasor scoring. Yeah.
With the right across each one. Yeah.
There should be like a score
for everything that happens
in the round and there
should be like ten nine for each event.
Like if they're standing up ten nine
Jon Jones Co control the standup.
But then John got it to the ground and
it was ten six cause he almost submitted
them, beat his shit out
of them, control them.
You know when it came to
take down defense, you know
this guy got the, you know,
and you could have it like that
and then count up the score.
But then that'd be tough to, if they're
on the ground for a small amount of time.
But that time they were on the ground.
This guy schooled that guy right there.
If they've got tens,
six for that. But that was like, that was,
well it depends on guns
and they've got no,
because if a guy goes
to the ground and yeah,
only for a few seconds, it's
not gonna mean anything, right.
You have to have a submission
attempt for it to mean something.
So if the guy just went to the ground,
they got back up,
I'd probably be a nine nine if a guy
takes you down and get back up and you get
immediately back up, it may be not
be even, but it's close to even.
I just think that if a judge
is properly educated on it,
then there'll be able to come close and
take all that into account and know that
that take down there were three takedowns
but he didn't do anything while he was
down or they got up straight
away. And I think if, yeah,
if there's a greater education on the,
on the judges that be out of work,
that system,
I wish I was English so I could say
straight away and say it like normal and
proper and that's a proper fight. Um, no,
you're right. But I just think
there's not enough variables. Um,
or think there's too many variables
rather and not enough accounting for those
variables in the current scoring system.
Why is it that they
bring hope, Dean and
all these great Jew, uh,
refs into each of these places yet?
It tends to be the judges are more local
thing and local or why couldn't they
have the same lab with the
judges are kind of elite.
Here's the 10 best judges who
are specialists in memory,
not a box in one weekend and kickboxing
or wrestling another weekend,
only do MMA and therefore be more,
well that's the local athletic
commissions have the say on
who gets to referee, who gets
the judge. And, uh, this,
it's an issue that we
deal with when we fight,
when we have a events in certain places
that don't have a lot of high level
fights.
So you'll have a local judges that were
appointed by the commissions and they're
on television and they're doing a terrible
fucking job and they do things like,
they get too involved there.
They have two big egos,
so they like get in the way of the action.
They tell guys to fight
and the guys are fighting.
They become a distraction
instead of enforcing the rules.
Seems to happen a lot less.
Like it seems to be that bring,
that would tend to choose the bigger
of refs from big events for big events.
It's critical.
If you have a big fight, you want an eve
Levine, you want herb dean, you know,
you want Josh Rosenthal before he went
to jail. Yeah. He want big John McCarthy.
You want somebody who's not going
to fuck up. You know it's hard.
Correct.
It is.
His coats on the seminar on referee and
then judging and I think he's just, yeah,
Mark's crate.
It's got such a good,
similar to herb in the
kind of the calmness in the
cage of knowing that. Yeah,
yeah. There's a lot of good guys
now. Yeah. Yes. It's a hard gig.
It's a very hard to dig them,
right.
Difficult to make the right decision
and you have to be on top of the action.
Can't let someone get hurt,
but you also can't stop a fight too soon.
And do you have to be very knowledgeable.
There's a lot going on there. You know,
there's a, it's, it's a very,
very stressful position that
doesn't get a lot of reward.
Like people don't appreciate
when they're really good,
but they get very upset if they're bad
and it's easy. It's an easy job
for everyone that isn't doing it.
It's easy to sit there and go,
ah, there you go. Yes. Yes.
That's, that's, that's absolutely
true. It's um, you know,
but that's true with a lot of things,
you know, watching it from the outside,
it looks like it'd be easy, but doing
that, it's way harder than what I do.
What I do is tricky but it's not
nearly as is hard as being a referee.
I think that's way harder. Those
guys, people get mad at them, man.
They stop fights too soon to push them
to get guys fucking scream at them,
you know like and they have to
be able to control shit too.
You know like when when things are going
down and you know if guys won't get off
of each other and they won't
stop hitting each other.
That's why I get nervous when I
see female referees and big men
cheffing experience in the cage is key
for a referee cause again always filled
the people like the people that
have actually fought or of train on,
on judge or referee and surely
that would benefit it will,
you know when someone needs help or
needs protected rather than yeah,
I have it. Having not experienced
it and kind of being outside on it.
I think that's a good
point. Yeah. I think multi,
most definitely having
some high level training,
most definitely understanding why
when a guy's in a bad position,
like on a guy's neck is about to get
hurt when a guy's arms about the snap.
You know, like when herb dean stopped
the Tim Silvia versus um, Frank Mir,
Frank Mir broke his arm and
herb jumped in and stopped it.
He heard the snap and he stepped
in and Jen and stop the action.
Didn't know or wouldn't,
yeah, it wasn't tapping. Yeah,
he wasn't tapping and he was
still trying to keep fighting.
He knew something wrong with his arm,
but he didn't know exactly what it was.
I mean,
that's because her has grappled,
he's fought MMA is very high
level martial artist himself,
so he knew there was a bad situation.
But like say if that was like someone who
had never trained and maybe it was out
of shape and just didn't recognize it,
that guy's arm could've got fucked up
really badly because if frank kept yanking
on it and he would have
kept yanking on it,
it wasn't going to let
that fucking thing go.
And he could have torn through the scan.
It could been a compound fracture,
could have been really,
really, really ugly. And uh,
I guess it is a compound fracture
when they both break. Yeah. But,
but when they puncture through the skin,
that's another level of severity because
you have to worry about infections and
it's like,
it's super dangerous.
And that could easily happen if you've
got the wrong guy who's reffing a fight.
Tough job. Very Leon Roberts is another
UK guys. Very good. Yeah, he's great.
He's excellent. There's a lot of
good guys that are doing it now.
There's a lot of good guys. It's uh, um,
there's a large group of people that
sort of grew up being MMA fans and got
involved in smaller shows and you
know, became like a, a trusted referee.
But you know, the gold standard.
So he's like John McCarthy,
Herb Dean, those goals.
And Rosenthal was great too, man.
Unfortunately we went to jail for that.
We'd son slang that weed. I've
been known as kind of phone. Yeah.
Apparently had some, some peace stole
lies she's not supposed to have,
they had to penalize. It's not
good. Roped. Have a good, yeah,
it sucked because he's a cool dude.
Yeah, he's a cool dude too. I mean,
I hope when he gets out
of jail they recognize it.
It wasn't a violent crime and
they reinstate him. But you know,
dudes in jail for like over a
year for weed. But you know,
I don't know what you're,
I guess it's like if you,
if you're selling medical marijuana,
it's legal statewide, but it's
not legal federally. So I dunno.
I guess you could still get
busted for it federally,
but he wasn't even doing
that was just slinging weed.
There was no federal involves. There's
like just getting paid selling plants,
which I support 100% yeah, I'm
tired. It's so stupid. It's is,
it's unbelievably stupid that it's
possible to lock someone in a cage for
selling plants in 2010 it's dumb as fuck.
I don't care if it's written on a
piece of paper, it's dumb as fuck.
Suddenly people who want the
implants and they want to know,
should he have guns on them know, probably
shouldn't have illegal guns on them.
That. I agree that Pos harder to argue
Jack Census. I'm not arguing that
the gun was not so much, but
yeah, no, I get that. It's crazy.
Yeah. It's just so sad and one day they're
going to look back and they're gonna,
they're gonna realize how unbelievably
stupid we were when it came to our drug
policies. Yeah, unbelievably stupid.
Like we took the most beneficial,
the least harmful ones and we made them
the most illegal and put people in jail
for the longest amount of time.
For those,
it's the perception of it is as far as,
remember when I was younger and I was
smoking a little weed and doing a lot of
of acid and and shit like that.
I read in good times,
good times and read in Timothy Leary's
thing of of when he was saying how the
way society looks at drugs is legal or
not legal when it like his argument was
it should be treated like
a car that you have to buy.
If you want to buy a seat, you
pass a test, you get your license,
you basically prove that
you're intelligent and of
sound mind enough to enjoy
this and then you go and buy it.
No,
like not because because the
one drug we've got an alcohol,
it's just you pay money and that's that.
Right? Anyone can have it. It's kind of,
yeah. I love that. The
first time I read that,
the small mindedness of
the way we approach it when
there's millions of ways to
approach the legalization of every drug.
Well,
it's also very strange when we
arbitrarily decide that one drug,
regardless of its impact on people's
health and wellbeing and crimes committed
under the influence of it, which is
like one of the most devastating ones,
alcohol and we make that our primary
drug and we just decide and one sad drug.
I'm behind that one. If
you get to do that, if you,
you're dealing with a sophisticated
intelligent civilization like the UK,
like the United States of America,
like the Western world in the year 2014
you're dealing with people that have
just previously impossible
levels of access to information.
It's unparalleled.
Access to information is never in human
history and yet in the face of this,
in the face of this overwhelming evidence,
you're choosing to put
people in cages for,
for plants like that.
That's it's,
it's, it's, it's,
it's an intolerable because we've
known it for so long that it's just,
except for with the same as we were
saying earlier with religion of how
ludicrous it is, but because it's
been there for so long, it's accepted.
It's exactly the same with that.
It's, I think it's changing.
Think dripping down and
start it again if that,
if that didn't happen in some
politician came in and said,
what are going to do is we're going to
put humans in cages and people look our
mental, that didn't already exist, so that
was a new thing. They'd be like, fuck.
Are you talking about about you putting
people in cages for plants that guys,
yeah, he's violated drug policy
number six five two nine zero.
He has more than one gram of marijuana
on him for personal consumption.
Get of that fucking cage.
Yeah. It's crazy. Just
change it in Brooklyn.
Didn't they just make Brooklyn
make weed legal in Brooklyn? Uh,
medical I think. Yes. I think New
York, so man, a medical in New York,
but I think they made edibles
legal. Really? Where in New York?
In New York, edibles are legal in
New York. Marijuana in New York.
Hmm. Hmm. That's nice. I
like hearing that Shit.
Florida was the opposite that everyone
told me like, well, you know, it's so bad.
If they find a seed in your car,
they will get you the other fuck
would you in Florida dude, they
only want cocaine. Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
It's a medical marijuana state as of
July 5th of 2014 so you can get medical
weed in New York. Good. Jesus Christ.
How is this 2014 it's happened.
Especially the medical,
which is by the way a Trojan horse,
but especially the medical
because the medical is, it's,
you can't argue against it.
People have inter-ocular pressure from
Glaucoma cures him. It helps relieve pain.
It helps,
uh,
regain the appetite of people that are
suffering from aids and on Chemo therapy.
It's like there's so many benefits.
It's impossible to argue medically.
And how long did you think it will be
before it just spreads over the country?
Because it seems that it works.
Everywhere is gone, right?
It's worked and it's good for
the economy and the best shit
is when we get the people in Iowa high.
That's what that's going to make the
world a way better place. All those tents,
dudes are out there. Deer
hunting, get those guys. I,
everybody needs to just, just get it.
It's a perspective enhancing moment.
That's what's going on here folks.
It does do,
I mean that everybody needs to get
high. No, I don't really mean that.
Everyone needs to get high.
You don't have, you're a
happy person the way you are.
Keep on keeping on,
so on.
But the idea that people can't benefit
from something that people have Colin
really benefited from,
not just benefited from have,
but have stated over and over
again that they benefited from it.
You don't hear that about a lot of other
drugs. This is a great drug, you know,
and there's a lot, I mean, I benefit
from several different drugs,
but like caffeine, I benefit
from caffeine. You know,
we don't like to think of it as a drug,
but that's a drug. It's an absolute drug.
And I, and I like it. I love coffee.
Marijuana is a very beneficial drug.
There's a lot of great aspects to it.
Can it be abused?
Of course everything can be abused.
Every single thing. Food can be abused,
but as grownups it should be a
choice that you can make. Right?
It's just about being disciplined. Growing
up. I mean, I'll stop smoking or stop.
I haven't had any marijuana in like over
10 years now, but it just wasn't, it.
It wasn't working out for me personally.
But that doesn't mean again, it's not,
I'm still very pro as as as I
think everyone should try or it,
it's positive to try all these things and
the idea that everyone is going to respond
exactly the same way that any given
substance,
whether it's aspirin or marijuana,
I mean there's a reason why some people
are allergic to some things and other
people in jail like shrimp. Some people
eat shrimp and they'll get sick as fuck.
I love shrimp. It's delicious.
My head to make it illegal.
I mean there's a good percentage of the
population that's allergic to shellfish.
It's a fairly common allergy.
And if they had chosen the same sort of
ideas that they have on like marijuana
addiction, this is one that they love to
throw around. Marijuana addiction. Yeah.
I would like to put marijuana addiction
next to shellfish allergy and see which
one is more common.
Yeah,
cause I bet shellfish allergy is way
more fucking common than marijuana.
And so the idea of making it illegal
because one tiny percentage of the
population gets physically addicted to it.
Well I don't know what's
going on in their body.
They might be physically addicted,
but for me,
I know I can stop and not have weed
for weeks and I don't feel any physical
pain. Nothing crazy. I've taken
two weeks off and had nothing,
not felt a thing. Not not an
urge, not just living life.
There's no want this no itch
that you can't scratch. Yeah.
It's weird that we have these arbitrary
decisions that get made a long time ago
and that they stick just because someone
wrote him somewhere. We're so goofy,
addictive personalities I guess or or,
or physical addiction,
but people will have that for anything.
Did you see the New York Times said that,
you know,
they did a New York Times editorial
saying that marijuana should be
decriminalized nationwide and
the government had a response.
The New York Times that was so goofy
and it included all this shit about
children,
about the effecting the brains of children
are like no one saying give pot the
fucking children. Did you even listen?
They didn't even read the editorial,
the editorials about adults
informed adults should be
allowed to smoke marijuana
and the government's thing,
like their response is all about kids.
It's like you goofy fake babysitters.
You don't give a fuck like kids.
You guys aren't in the hood. You guys
out in the hood saving babies. Fuck off.
Fuck off. You're not, you're not looking
after kids is not hurting kids. Stop it.
No one's saying kids should go get
high. Jesus Christ. It's ridiculous.
Goofy fucks. But that's the kind
of people that are responsible.
That's the kind of people
that are responsible for our
laws are who's saving the
kids from shellfish? Who's, who's,
who's out there fighting that battle?
They try to say peanuts are
a big one, man. Yeah. Nuts.
Free schools like the schools.
My God,
my daughter goes to my daughter
goes to a nut free school. Yeah.
Why did they still have nuts on
airplanes like I, they still do it.
Why wouldn't they just
switched to cheezits or
something? Like why is it nuts?
Anyway, screw question. Is it
something with nuts and flying?
There's tons of things like that though.
Like the realization
making me want nuts common.
But [inaudible] was talking about how
out how come when epilepsy came about or
we didn't go. All right. All right.
We don't need strobe lights then on.
And this is how that could kill you. Send
her into a fit. Let's get rid of them.
That's fine. We don't need, they're
not, unless it's like, no, we need,
we need to party my friend, just strobe
light. This is his wife would black out.
She would see like one of those videos
online. Ah, just put them somewhere else.
I thought he was fucking around.
You remember that Guy Jim from the message
board? Yeah. He um, he put some, uh,
some warning up like saying like, Hey,
you guys take down these fucking strobes.
And then of course everybody changed
their Avatar to a strobe. Like fuck off.
Maybe just shut off avatars instead
of killing the party is if you like,
you know, didn't know that you're going
to see something. And if you saw it,
it was black you out.
You'd have to be like really careful
about your viewing habits, you know.
There we go. Don't do
that. I'm not. People die.
You shouldn't do that. That's
rude as fuck. That's going
to bring the aliens back.
If you do that, they're gonna
come back and land it's sea sick.
Secret signal here.
There was some radio signals they
just found in the galaxy recently.
Fascinating new radio signals found in
the galaxy and people were speculating as
to whether or not it's a aliens.
What does it sound like?
Does it sound like static or is it,
I don't think it's like a sound.
I think it's like a signal.
Radio waves emitted from nearby
galaxy. Wow. Yeah. That's interesting.
Shit man. July 10th mysterious
signal from a galaxy far,
far away.
Brief pulse detected by the Arecibo
telescope appears to come from far beyond
our galaxy.
Could be caused by evaporating black
holes or mergers of neutron stars or
aliens. Could be aliens.
Could it be aliens? Yes.
There's a chance they could be trying
to reach us. It could be a chance.
Did you see that video that somebody
shared it to me on Twitter where they can
take sound waves off video of like a
plant and like map it out and it will
recreate what the sound was when
that video was recorded. Yeah,
well they can use a Doritos bag. Yeah.
Doritos bag. You see saw that video.
That was nuts. Incredible. So if
you're in a room and say like you're
talking and you have like a Doritos bag,
they're like a light piece of paper,
they can focus on that.
And the s the impact of your
voice on that Doritos bag.
They can detect what you were saying.
They can detect the sounds. What?
Yeah.
See if I can find that video that was,
that is the mind blower of
the week's mind. Blowers.
What are we getting excited about cameras
earlier and let's fucking insight how
much smarter or those people than me.
There's so much smarter.
Like that's not even a human like anybody
can figure that out. Like wouldn't.
When I think about my
potential for figuring things
out and their potential for
figuring things out, like you know the
tools that they have, the the, the,
the steps that they are head.
I could live a hundred lives and never
even catch up to where they never even
get close.
It's amazing.
Like when people want to pretend
that all people are created equal,
why don't you pay attention?
There's some mother fuckers out there
that are getting sound off Doritos bags
and guess what? Fuck face. They're
smarter than you. They're just,
their brains work better.
Here we go.
The results of this video or the
best experience through heads,
when sound hits an object,
it causes that object to vibrate.
The motion of this vibration creates
this subtle visual signal that's usually
invisible to the naked eye.
In our work,
we show how using only a video of
the object and as suitable processing
algorithm,
we can extract these minute vibrations
and partially recover the sounds that
produced them letting us turn
everyday visible objects,
individual microphones.
It's crazy.
Fuck the silent high
speed video shown here.
On the left we see the leaves of a
potted plant shown on the right video was
recorded while in nearby
loudspeaker, played the notes
to Mary had a little lamb.
Oh my God.
So now what they're gonna do,
they record it with the sound and
they're going to play it back using,
even when we played the
video in slow motion here,
the vibrations caused by the music are
so subtle that they moved the plant's
leaves by less than a hundredth of a pixel
making the plant appears still to the
naked eye,
but by combining and filtering all of the
tiny motion happening across the image
that you see,
we are able to recover this sound.
Oh my God.
Seven in the future where we're going
be able to take a little video and find
out what we're really talking about
where JFK or something, oh my God.
Oh my God.
Six we five human speech from high speed
video of a bag of chips lying on the
ground,
but to make things a little
more challenging this time
we put the camera outside
behind a soundproof window.
This is what a cell phone was able to
record from inside next to the bag of
chips.
Okay.
Fleece was white as snow and everywhere.
That very well that lamb would,
and this is what
we were able to recover from high
speed video filmed from outside behind
soundproof glass
that's haunting.
Oh my gosh,
that's amazing.
So what that's going to happen is we're
going to be able to take old home movies,
especially like the eight millimeter kind.
That's like no sound that used to have
in the 70s we're going to be able to
eventually probably take that and actually
recreate the sound of everything that
was going on. How can those be part? As
long as they have the real nub number.
This on the film at the same
resolution as, as an example,
they're going to show it now at a very
lower resolution at this part of the
video and that this is early on.
So I think in the future they're going
to be able to get it to the point of
being able to do that because here's what
they can do with just a typical camera.
Uh, right. Like a to a laptop.
Yeah. Yeah. So here I'll show
which can record thousands of in
most consumer cameras. Here we go.
We can sometimes actually recover sound
at frequencies several times higher than
the frame rate of our video letting us
recover audio from video captured on
regular consumer cameras.
Here we see a 60 frames per second video
of a bag of candy capturing a regular
consumer Dslr.
While our Mary had a little lamb music
played through a nearby loudspeaker.
[inaudible]
and 60 frames is like half the
speed that the iPhone can do. Okay.
That's fucking saying
[inaudible]
this is so strange.
By using a variation of our technique
on the rows of the recorded video,
we were able to recover this audio,
which includes frequencies more than
five times higher than the frame rate of
our camera.
[inaudible].
So yeah. Wow. Expect new, crazy
ghosts in the future from the past
weird, weird world we live in. Man.
What a weird world that
someone can figure that out.
That's bothersome of control if you get
out in the first place is just insane.
Just the actual thing of having the idea
and perception of thinking of that is
just,
yeah, yeah. That's a real game
changer, right? Yeah. Wow.
So humbling. Yeah. You know,
it's like I really feel when I see
something like that that we're in,
we're very fortunate in the time that
we live that we're going to get to see
these things.
Yeah.
There were a part of this insane moment
in history where things are becoming so
complicated, so quickly, so powerful,
so quickly. The, the impact of them,
the impact of people's words, just,
it's never been a time like this.
What's the speed of it all is insane.
Like the speed that
the chain or the or the speed. We went
from the invention of the Internet,
which is putting everyone in the world
in touch with everyone else and then the
speed went from that to turn it into
something that we just look at tips on and
tweet people and talk
shit coming the the speed,
which we've just become comfortable with
this amazing piece of technology that
we should be using to find
out amazing things constantly.
But 90% of the time we've
got so comfortable with it
because it's just on your
phone now. It's not, it's not this,
this great jump in technology
that well we take it for granted.
It's doing its work. Yeah. And it's doing
its work and its work is connecting.
All of us connecting all of a sudden mean
we're connected in some really bizarre
ways now, man, that's a,
I mean what we're seeing on the screen,
we're watching this video that's a
fascinating new thing and an amazing new
thing,
but it's probably one of like a million
new things that are coming out that are
going to freak us the fuck out. You know,
all this stuff is essentially magic.
It's crazy
how the F or freak us
out for like a minute
and then be [inaudible]
and then it's just fine.
It's going to be an
accurate thing. Yeah, sure.
It'll be an APP on your phone and two
years it's creating time traveled by using
it like weird like old VCR type kind
of technology where we're going to be
recreating everything
that's ever happened. Yes.
So crazy on tree DNA or something.
So weird man. Yeah. You're gonna be able
to like watch an outdoor video and watch,
look,
stare at the trees,
listen to the actual voices that the
people were saying while there were near
those trees.
Well not only that,
the probably be able to like do things
digitally to change the resolution of
things.
I feel like probably some sort of an
algorithm where they'll like be able to
analyze each individual
pixel on Hanse in post the,
the camera's reaction to the image and
change it and enhance it and recreate
reality based on some sort of an
understanding of the surroundings.
I love the idea that this
technology could come about though,
but tha tha tha tha tha foible of it
would be they have to be near a plant or a
diary
package. Sometimes we've had
these great moments in history,
but it wasn't next to a plant walk.
We'll never know what,
where would that, where would
we, where would a safe place be?
Would it be underwater or
would it know? Well, would it
that'd be worse.
Imagine if they figured
out a way to watch,
oh, well I say around at three a
packets from now on. I don't want to,
can somebody top smell shit,
shit. Stay away from Doritos.
I shouldn't
say figure out a way to recreate old
historical videos and actually make them
like a part of the oculus rift.
Make them like super high resolution.
Calculate them based on all that.
Like say if they took the
Kennedy assassination and
they calculated it on all
known photographs of the area, they did
a very comprehensive analysis. They,
they in detail,
every photo of Kennedy's face ever taken.
Every photo of Jackie o ever taken every
inch of one of those crazy limousines
that Kennedy was driving in the
convertible limousines, every inch of it.
And then they put you in a virtual reality
where you're at the scene and you've
got to watch the Zapruder film play out.
Yeah. Like right there, like you're there,
you're looking at Zapruder
holding the camera and you know,
you could move around on,
I mean,
miss sounds like this whore ripper,
you know,
like, because the sounds from
reflections of like, yeah,
they'll figure out a way to,
yeah.
You wonder if you'll ever be able to
accurately like replay the voices.
Yeah.
Huh.
But recreations of historical events in
three dimension in virtual reality is
inevitable. Like, I mean, if people
are making paintings of Nixon,
they're definitely going to make like a
virtual reality scenario where he gets
shot at the theater.
Yeah.
You get to see John Wilkes booth
sneak up behind him and shoot him.
They're going to have that pace
note. Yeah. Yeah. Historical events.
Any known historical events,
you know,
I'm writing as a story or song
or whatever at the moment.
About a guy that gets a chance to
meet some kind of God or whatever,
but gets told you can have one truth and
you've got to pick everything for our
history.
Like you could pick like to know what
happened with JFK or to know if Jesus was
real or wherever. And just
what, what would that one,
I mean in this story he ends up going
through all of that and then asking if his
girlfriend cheated on him because that's
the reality doesn't match the reality.
That's the truth that you'd
ask and need to know. But what,
what the fuck would you, it's weird
cause JFK is one that always come to it.
I'm the American, I've got no, I think
it's just cause it's such a conspiracy.
The want to know the
actual truth can amazing.
I think the, the, the actual
truth would be interesting,
but I'm pretty convinced of a
conspiracy when it came to JFK. I've,
I've seen the evidence that
Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
And one of the things that I don't find
compelling is that there was obviously
some,
the Warren Commission had a predetermined,
predetermined conclusion
that they wanted to reach.
And that was that there was a lone gunman
and they wanted to reach it so badly
that they ignored evidence to the contrary
and even concocted crazy stories like
the magic bullet theory. Yeah. Yeah.
They only did that because they had to
account for a bullet that hit a underpass
and ricocheted.
So they had an account.
They had to make all these wounds come
out of one bullet cause they know there's
only three shots from Gospel.
The only reason why they
did it is to wrap up there.
It wasn't like a scientific analysis,
like they looked at it all.
It was done by Orrin Hatch, who's,
uh, he's, uh, was it Orrin Hatch?
I think it was single bullet theory.
I want to say it was him.
It was one of those fucking
Weirdos from, um, the, um,
[inaudible] remember when I'm
Anita Hill and Clarence Thomas?
And there was a, do you know who
Anita Hill isn't Claire's tank?
Clarence Thomas Supreme Justice who uh,
when they were trying to appoint him,
there was this crazy story that came out.
Like he, uh, told this woman Anita Hill,
that's really sexy black
check. He told her that, uh,
there's a pubic hair and her coke.
I remember that.
Do you ever find a coke,
like the sales went up during that
time or was it like Pepsi sales?
I bet that'd be fascinating.
I wonder. Right.
Pubic hair makes me want to buy Pepsi.
Arlen Specter. Sorry. That's who he was.
It wasn't Orrin Hatch was Arland spectrum,
but I think a Orrin hatch
was involved in as well,
but aren't Arlen Specter was just
like this known creeper. He's just a,
he was just one of those guys that
had been around. He was a Democrat,
switched to Republican, then switched
back to Democrat and he's just a shift.
He fucking character. And he was the one
who came up with a single bullet theory.
He was the guy who was his idea.
How would you say one bullet
just went fucking nutty.
It's crazy that they would even consider
triage is shit law that on something.
That's clearly the biggest case.
Gentlemen,
good to be the most scrutinized thing,
but I think some of the eight 20 in
saying that it's stupid that they can be
equally as saying that they would
think, yeah, all that that we'll do,
we'll tell the people that,
but it did work.
I mean there's people that are arguing
today, so they were right. Like if,
whether or not they were right or not,
I'm not sure,
but they were right that people would
accept the fact that this one bullet
doesn't enough image to put that there.
I mean,
it's so preposterous in so many different
ways and I have conversations with
people, but you can't deny the
actual bullets dimensions itself.
The bullet itself was in pristine
condition of we've, you know,
people hate this conversation because
it's been done so many times before,
but there's also fragments of
it that it was left in the body.
The body is of Connelly, especially
where they weren't accounted for.
They weren't missing for the bullet.
They found the Gurney.
That wasn't a bullet that
did all that just wasn't,
it's not a bullet that shattered bone.
It just wasn't fucked up enough.
It just doesn't make any sense much more
likely since it was found on the Gurney
at the hospital.
It's somebody placed it there and to
pretend that people wouldn't place it.
There is preposterous.
The find a pristine bullet on a Gurney
on governor colleagues journaly Gurney in
the hospital.
Do you assume that someone place it or
do you assume that this is a bullet that
went through to people and just
happened to wind up on a Gurney?
Either one of those is true or either
one of those as possible rather,
you know th th the the say that you
absolutely know that that's the single
bullet and this is the
reason why I know it's,
it easily could be placed there
and if it was placed there,
your whole theory of one bullet doing
that, then we have no bullet. Like what's,
where's the bullet that did all
this and what does it look like now?
Well it looks one,
sometimes you don't know.
So because he like finding the bullet
was the only reason why people were
willing to believe that one bullet
did all this damage. So they ha,
which is really ridiculous because
you would think that would be contrary
because like this is a bullet that
was like shot into a swimming pool or
something. It doesn't look fucked up at
all. Yeah. I don't know, man. That the,
the either or thing is a problem as well.
Everybody wants to say Lee Harvey
Oswald acted alone. No, he did.
And it was a conspiracy.
Could be Lee Harvey Oswald
was a part of the conspiracy.
Yeah, that's possible too. Yeah, they
could've, he could've been there. Patsy,
like he said, I was a Patsy, but he
also could have been involved in it,
which would account for the,
the slang of the officer,
like a police officer was shot and they
attributed that to Lee Harvey Oswald.
He might've shot a cop because
he was a guilty fuck. You know,
he might've been in volume,
might've been one of the gunmen.
They might've been several gunman and
they might've just had that guy like set
up as a patsy from the jump because he
had a wife that was Russian and he was
from Russia. Either way that
killed Kennedy, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't go back to see that.
I'll go back to go to Roswell.
Yeah, I'd want to see if for a Ufo crashed
or it was just a fucking air balloon,
but the hot air balloon surely would.
That one feels to me like it would if,
if it could potentially have the
most disappointing outcome. Yes.
I'm looking forward to this and then
go, ah, fuck. It wasn't an air balloon.
I want my to confirm my suspicions
and my suspicions are like,
this is my suspicions when it comes
to [inaudible]. This is the big one.
I think that people are full of shit.
I think that there's enough full of shit
people to count for some really good
stories about Ufos.
Yeah.
Has anybody ever experienced an
actual Ufo from another planet?
It is absolutely possible. That's not
what I'm saying. I'm not discounting.
If you're the one person out there that
actually has a real unique experience
with a Ufo and you're not crazy,
I'm not discounting you,
but what I'm saying is when I look at
all the evidence with the Roswell and all
these different stories and all
these different crash stories,
so people are so full of shit that
it's much more likely knowing the small
number of these things that
actually get reported you.
When people say thousands
of sightings every year,
there's 350 million
people in this country.
If you only get thousands
of sightings every year,
what are the odds of those people
being crackpots? 100% yeah,
it might be 100% it was not a
hundred it's 99.999999 crazy.
It never happens to a really
regular [inaudible] and we can't,
we, we must account for the number of
crazy people that we have that we've,
we've counted.
There's a lot of them.
So if people are just having
these episodes where they
start telling you about
UFO abductions and seeing ships that
are invisible and move faster than time.
Like it's also possible,
they're crazy and full of shit like that.
So I would love to go back and if I went
back to Roswell and I found an actual
Ufo fucking change my tune.
But if I went back to Roswell and I
would just saw a bunch of people standing
around a weather balloon, it's, it's good
that you are one is isn't going back to,
it's kind of about to, to disprove
something rather than witness. This is,
this is what happened. It's like, no
this didn't happen. Fuck that shit.
I absolutely bullshit you come
come up with any of this anymore.
Well I think I would like to be
open minded. Like we'll look,
no one would like it more
than me. If I went back and I actually
saw spaceships from another planet. Like,
if you could go to area 51 and they could
take you to the Bob Blazar place where
they have this fucking gigantic hangar
and you go inside and you see it,
that actual alien Ufo. Holy
Shit, I would love that.
But it's way more likely to me that you
get there and you see a bunch of remote
control shit that the government's
been working on and you see like some,
you know aircraft technology
that led to the stealth bomber,
which they know they built out of there.
That's more likely with the UFO is our,
yeah, that makes more sense.
Although little is back
engineering alien technology.
Oh I don't see a lot of evidence of that.
That seems,
that seems like you
discounting human ingenuity,
which is obviously fucking amazing. Like
look at this sound thing. Exactly. Yeah.
We are looking at already it's that back
engineered from aliens who want to see
what we're saying. Yes.
Distance. So I think you,
you're dealing with a lot of Dell minded
people that can't even comprehend the
intelligence level of the people that
can conceive something like a stealth
bomber. So they're seeing this, these,
this technology arising there,
back engineered.
They're attributing it to back engineering
ufs when it really could just be
people that are so smart,
so much smarter than them.
They're not even the same
species. Yeah. Essentially. Yeah.
And they're just super fucking smart and
they figured out a gang of shit. Yeah.
That's way more likely right.
Lately. So the, the, the,
the people who work for the government
that have made it are aliens essentially,
in a way that much further advanced
than right. US. That's that stats.
The proof of aliens and Steven,
tell me he's on nailing that.
There is an alien. What's, what is he?
He's a computer voice, right? Yeah.
And he is a,
is a brain that's connected very loosely
biologically to some movements that
control computer.
It's essentially a brain
directly interfacing with
a computer through fingers
book alien. He's a classic guy. Helium
right there. Any warns us about aliens
is warning us about him. He's covering
his own tracks so much harder.
The plain sight right in front of us.
Pretended he can't move and waiting
and then he'll open up like the thing.
It'd be a fucking mouth and
chopped down in someone's head,
but in a sense petrifying in a sense.
He's an alien in that he's so,
he's like, he is something
that we can't even imagine.
We can't even imagine what's
going on in inside of his mind.
He is so goddamn smart. He's so
advanced that his concepts and his,
the levels that he's
operating on thinking on,
might as well be alien to some guy who
works at Krispy Kreme and keeps fucking
up and doesn't figure out which
button to press. You know?
Shouldn't say Krispy Kreme. Wonderful
establishment makes fine. Dawn's,
what's the deal with that line for
that though? So they're delicious.
There's like 30 car deep in Burbank.
Every time I drive by I'm
like one day I like to try it.
It's not because they suck.
We usually do the Burbank one
is the shit dude cause it's 24
hours a day you need to do is come
home from a comedy club some night.
I've done that for coming home
from the Ice House. Stop off,
get some Krispy Kreme.
Got Hello.
It's like one in the morning and
there's a line of 30 people gluten free.
No God, no gluten free. Now
you're getting full sugar.
It's going to go right to your arteries.
You're going to feel like shit
for hours after you eat it.
But for the mouth pleasure that you
get for those that minute or so.
Are you eating one of those?
It's worth with those hours,
easily a pussy. You know,
what do you think is going
on with this Ferguson thing?
Cause I'm looking at it now, like they
just arrested the huff pro reporters,
the arresting reporters. They're
going into the Mcdonald's and going,
everyone needs to leave like employees.
Why we're gonna Arrest,
you know who to fall is
Westley low rate is w.
E.
S. L. E. Y. L. O. W.
E. R. Y. He writes for,
I think the Washington Post is formally
of the Boston Globe and the La Times
Huffington
post reporter arrested in
Ferguson. Yeah. It's uh,
it says Ryan J. Ryan.
Oh Ryan J. Riley Rather.
This is fucking crazy.
Why Ryan J.
Riley and the Washington Post is Wesley
Lowery were arrested Wednesday while
covering the protests in Ferguson,
Missouri surrounding the death of an
unarmed African American teenager,
Michael Brown, who was shot to death by
police by a police officer last week.
Riley tweeted that around 8:00 PM the
Swat officers invaded the McDonald's at
which he was working requested
information after he took a photo of them.
Lowery was also working at the
fast food restaurant. Whoa.
Wait a minute. How are Huffington
post reporters arrested? Oh,
huffpost caused the Ferguson Baba Baba
status of Riley after tweets that he had
been arrested. The person who picked
up the phone identified himself.
As George said, he couldn't give
any information at this time.
So who got arrested?
Infused repair for the West?
Yes,
I'm a Los Angeles Times reporter.
Matt Pearce talked to
the police department
and this guy used to work for
the Boston Globe and looks,
offers slurs slammed me into a fountain
soda machine because I was confused at
which door they were asking
me to walk out. And he's,
this is a reporter that was
waiting to be taken away.
Large black man screaming for help in the
back of police truck. Whoa. I'm dying.
I'm dying. Please call the, he screamed.
Yeah. I'm still trying to
figure out which huffing
posts guy find got arrested.
Also Ryan really of huff pro assaulted.
Interested.
Wow. So those guys, so who, why does
it say that there? Oh, I get it.
I'm sorry. They were working
on their laptops at Mcdonald's.
That's not right. A working
for McDonald's. Right. Oh Wow.
So they came in while they were working
and they ask for their ID and when they
took a photo,
Holy Shit.
Like that's like beyond
overstepping bounds.
There was also a video that someone put
up online of some people filming cops
and the cop point to gun arm and
tells him to get the fuck out of here.
And they all start screaming.
It's really crazy shit at the cops
says get the fuck out of here.
And he points the gun at them. You
know, it's, it's some dark shit man.
It's,
this is all what everyone was
terrified of when that um,
that operation, um, or that a occupy
Wall Street shit was going on.
What they were worried most does that
at one point in time, the United States,
there's going to have something,
something that just wakes people up to
shit like this and they actually start
writing. You know. And that's a
terrifying thing for, for police.
It's a terrifying thing for law
enforcement for before you know,
any form of government. When you
have this, this happen, these things,
these types of things, they
build momentum. It gets,
it gets real scary when people feel
like the police is doing them wrong and
people,
they have a,
there's a battle between people in the
police and they start shooting rubber
bullets had crowds like
they're doing here.
They're just hitting random people in
the crowds trying to disperse them.
You can't do that, man. This
is, this is dangerous shit.
This is how people get
overthrown was a pitcher from it.
You know the Shah of Iran got overthrown.
One of the,
one of the reasons why they,
they rose up against him is because he
was starting to say that they were going
to attack people if they were in any
sort of formation for more than two or
three people were together and
they formed any sort of a group,
they're going to arrest them all,
shoot him onsite next day.
There's like 2 million. We
have a breaking point. Yeah.
As things have gone right.
We can't, yeah. Yeah. We'll,
we'll just tough because there's always
going to be a load of smaller breaking
points along the way that don't cause
the chain but change but calls a lot of
bad, bad. Yeah.
This is crazy and actions crazy that
they feel like that they can just arrest
people that are in Mcdonald's.
Like are you protecting or serving when
you're doing that? Which one? Yeah.
What are you doing?
Guys are in Mcdonald's.
There were reporters and you're allowed
to just come in and disturb them because
you think the what? They took a photo
of some crazy shit that's going down.
You don't want to being
released is this protocol,
are you following like this is like a,
is this in your book of
what you're supposed to do?
They were arrested for not packing
their bags quick enough. Wow.
Solaris.
They can just decide to come into
McDonald's and kicked everybody else out.
Meanwhile, the streets are flooded
with people. That's so strange.
Why would they kick everyone
out of Mcdonald's anyway?
Yeah. Is that, I don't know.
Mcdonald's is property. I think
when, when shit hits the fan,
when you have a situation like this and
people from the police and civilians are
fighting, it's like things get real hairy
and there's a lot of like huge, huge,
huge mistakes that get made and there's
a lot stress and a lot of pressure and
it's going to be real tough
to calm fucking thing down
and it just spread so much
more now because of Twitter
and because of everything
else it becomes this. Everyone
knows about it, which yeah,
as far as it all out more. Right. Most of
the time you live in England, right? Yeah.
And in England the cops don't have
guns right now. So is there ever any,
this kind of riding still
has been yet there's um,
a break.
You put a regular police don't have guns,
but there are oversee like different
units or higher up things where it can be
the case in, yeah. Yeah. There has been,
it was a couple of years ago,
there was a big one where a kid was show
because they fought, he was now armed.
Armed police had been called out for an
incident and the guard wasn't armed and
it caused a riots for days and days.
Kind of in London,
but similar type of situation.
It's just not as regular and not as as
far railroad because yet it's not any
policeman, the policeman in Mcdonald's
or wherever else, not everyone has go.
Yeah. Is weaponized. That's a weird
thing. How does the police deal?
Like how often is violent
crime with guns take place?
How often does that in England,
it's not that regularly.
Is there is that again as
everywhere there are guns,
there are knives like there
is crime going on, but yeah,
it's no where near as as regular thing
[inaudible] even proportionately,
obviously there's millions and millions
more people in the u s but still say
percentage wise it's far more regular.
Yeah.
And every now and then
there's like some sort of a,
like that Lee Marie situation where they
had that crazy bank robbery. Yeah. That,
that was fucking nuts,
man. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Full armor on and masks and you know,
Ski Matt Ski Goggles on and Shit.
You couldn't see their faces.
And it's weird because stuff,
right? That wasn't that,
that you thought that wasn't that big
a news story coming. It was, it wasn't,
no, it was the biggest bank robbery
in all of England. Right? Again, yeah.
But it wasn't,
it,
it wasn't as again lies because as the
riots over a kid getting shot or just,
I don't know, bank robberies aren't as
hot. It's a favor these days. Are they?
I don't know. It's weird. I think it's
way harder to rob a bank. I don't,
I don't think that happens all that often.
And the Lee Marie one was one
of the biggest ones ever. Yeah.
I mean him and his alleged compadres,
I mean they heisted some
insane amount of money. Right.
It was a hundreds of millions
of dollars. Crazy amounts. Yeah.
That guys are crazy story, Huh? Yeah. How
much of a folk hero is he in England? No,
genuinely not that much joy. Again,
I heard about it more because of,
of I heard about that whole story more
because of who he is and because of his
father in Everett because of
mixed martial arts. Yeah. Hm.
So the other people that were involved,
how I became aware of it and again,
I can't say, I guess other people may
have been more aware for some reason,
but yeah, that's the main, that's how I
heard about the story more because of MMA.
Yeah.
He doesn't even seem like a real person,
like guy who fought as a high level.
I'm a May fighter got stabbed like
seven times and then one being involved,
one of the biggest bank robberies,
every second stories.
And he goes away to Morocco and he's in
prison and Morocco and just run and shit
over there. He's living over there for a
while and then eventually got arrested.
And where's he down in jail. Is he in
jail? The UK? I think so. Wow. He's a,
he's got a crazy life man.
Someone's going to take that guy's life
and turn it into like the most insane
Guy Ritchie movie ever. You know,
like it's just him narrating it.
It's going to eat
w w I want him to Ryan
because it's all just there.
It's just literally tell you yes
stories. England has a lot of violence.
We'll Bullock fisticuffs. Yeah, that's,
that's something that I've found
like shocking when I was there.
How often you see guys
duking it out in the street?
It's a weird one. I'm a,
I'm a, I'm a Millwall fan,
which is a football team over there
and we're known for having a lot of
hooligans and violence of writing and
they're known as the worst of the lot
coming. But again, it's,
so my opinion is that's not exclusive
to football really in the UK,
if you're on an generally on a Saturday
night, if you're in a busy town center,
you can see a front if someone,
so it's gonna cause we drink so heavily,
Doug's then hope a great bit about Helen
England to just fight about everything.
Where are you from over here?
Fuck over there.
That's exactly right.
It is. It's just such a strange
thing. Do you think, I wonder if,
how much of that is
related to the fact that,
I mean his direct descendants, when
you're in Europe, there's no clean break.
It's not like your family comes over
to a new continent, forms a, you know,
a new civilization and starts fresh.
No,
you're essentially riding on the
momentum of King George. You know,
it's like the same, you know, like
the society has moved and progressed
tiny little island. But we've got this
and you used to be a massive empire. Yeah.
You know, affect things, right.
Our whole history is running
so much of the world.
And then we're on this tiny little island
still claiming that we're the mighty
England,
but we just scrapping in the
streets amongst ourselves.
Isn't it weird how civilizations do that?
Like the culture is like rise and fall,
rise and fall and their influence and
their power. You know, Rome go to Rome,
man, shit there. Nothing's going
on. I go buy a pizza. I mean,
what are you going to
get when you go to Rome?
You're not gonna see any just
giant armies. They had any,
it's the weird delusional in Britain. I
have a history and an arrogance in a way.
90% of the stuff that we got that
was good was from the Romans.
The Romans came and showed us and the
reason a lot of our society crumbled after
the Romans left was because we had all
these amazing roads and everything,
but we didn't know how to rebuild them
all to maintain them or anything like
that.
So we kind of had this big boom when the
Romans came over and then plummeted for
ages because we're like,
oh shit,
we've got all this technology and what
not and we don't really know how to fix
that.
Some other guys made it and then they
went broken it to go home cause they got
overthrown and we were
there like, ah, fuck.
And then years later he was then turned
into accurate history and our great
advances in technology and
yeah, it comes in waves, right? Yeah.
Like guys figured it out
and then something happens.
Then the new people have to
reinvent and yeah, that's a,
it's just such a fascinating thing.
It's such a fascinating thing when
you go to Europe and you see how old
everything is. Yeah. It really puts into
perspective because, uh, when I was a kid,
I lived in Boston and uh, there
was a cemetery, uh, near, uh,
the Commons and uh,
it's like one of the oldest cemeteries
in the country and you like see like a
headstone from like the 17 hundreds
or 1600. So that's a big deal.
But in comparison to the European history,
like they have that big,
big white horse that's
on the side of a hill.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And nobody
fucking knows where it came from.
Nobody has a god car wash,
stuff like that.
And just things like stone
Henge and all that kind of just,
it's just crazy how old that,
and again,
really it's not that impressive.
It's a load of slabs. It's some shit,
but it's the fact that
this is, yeah, so old.
Thousands of years ago as
well and no, Whoa, whoa. Yeah.
They like to bait the purpose
of like they find roads,
these crazy stone roads and like, okay,
what the fuck? What's going on here?
No one knows. Everyone
forgot. It's all just gone.
Whole civilization comes and goes and
it's a beautiful thing though, man. It's,
it's an amazing thing to discover the
remnants of the past and try to piece
together what happened and then really
try to put it into perspective what has
happened that brought us to 2014 all the
different lives that had to be lived,
all the events that had to take place.
And all the different things that we're
trying to still piece together today and
try to figure out, well what, what was
going on? What did they believe on,
why would they worshiping cows and where
were they doing on top of this hill and
what was this, why they set this
up to align it with constellations?
Like what was their belief system?
They wrote like this,
what the fuck they got these little
squiggly lines. What are they saying?
Crazy to think of the level of
intelligence that was around
before the breakthrough was made to
record that and to document that.
So just so much stuff.
Just amazing shit that probably they all
knew what these stones before everyone
knew what the fuck it was full,
but that wasn't,
that wasn't written down anywhere. We're
not going to forget that we come home.
We spend so much time
building this as Donald's.
Everyone knows what the stones or the
WHO does this tone and everybody knows
what's done in just for,
yeah.
I wonder when the first guy
started writing shit down,
everybody else was like probably like,
what the fuck are you doing? He's like,
I wrote a language like I'm not learning
your shit. I got my own language,
my language is involved. Just circle
solve a big circles and little circle.
Big circles or means I'm really mad.
Little circles mean them happy. Okay.
Big Circle.
A little circle.
You had to get a bunch of people to
agree like you had to get a bunch of
scholars,
many generations.
How many generations is the tech to
figure that out imaginable and then
someone's like,
I'm going to write it on our cylinder
and I'm going to roll it on clay.
Do you get to know what I mean? Like
what I'm, how fucked up is it that I,
when I then go and find another society
that got at completely different,
no correlation at all.
So not only have you got to figure out
this completely new way of communicating,
you've got to then interpret
their way into yours.
It's too crazy. Just
the idea. Oh, how much,
how Craig look when,
when you think about like
Columbus in 1492 sailing off,
finding the Americas landing here,
seeing the native people,
trying to communicate with them.
Like what that must have been like not
even knowing where the fuck you landed.
You get there and you see some people
and they're all brown and Shit and they
got feathers in their head and
like what is going on? Cause they,
how do I tell this guy that
I'm from Spain? Like what
do I, you know what, what?
What is he saying?
Like you had to decipher a language that
no one even knew existed and there's a
gang of them. You got the
Lakota people who speak one way.
You get the Cherokee
that speak another way.
You get the Apache that have
their own way. Yeah. Pool.
That's the only 200 years ago,
you know,
400 500 years or whatever it was from
1492 to 2012 I mean think about like when
they came here,
the,
the amount of time between
1492 the less than 600 years,
500 plus years to today.
That's nothing in terms of the world.
Nothing.
But in that time,
this one spot with a bunch of people on
horses just hanging out, just erupted,
became a New York City, San Francisco,
California. Last time I was here,
I can't remember what it was, but someone
was telling me how long ago it was.
The La was part of Mexico. 18
hundreds it's not. Yes. Yeah.
Not that ago one. Okay.
When was la? Mexico?
I say it was,
I say 1800.
That really could be wrong. I could be
remembering it wrong. But Brian, you,
Dayton a Mexican. I was at a Mexican
last night, but if you do you to ask,
have you had a guess?
When was la?
Mexico 1821 [inaudible] 27.
Okay. When was la? Mexico. Hmm?
When did la belonged to
Mexico. Okay. When did did,
it's the anticipation now
and now it's building.
I'm saying more recently than that. You
saying, I don't know. I don't want to,
uh, 1769. Oh, really? 1769.
Thanks. So hold on a second.
European exportation period from 1542
to 76, nine, seven. Oh, no, no, no.
I'm [inaudible], um,
Mexican beer at 1821 1848.
The United States State Hood, dude,
that she continues to the present day.
1821 I guessed it. Date. Yeah.
That's amazing. You probably,
do you think maybe you
had that in your head
as you knew
I got a little Mexican juice on me.
Maybe.
Do you think that maybe you saw that?
So it's a crazy number 1821.
It is a real, incredibly specific, yeah,
it's really specific, but you got it.
But it's also,
I've seen those tee shirts.
That's one thing to
take into consideration.
They have a t shirt that says 1881 to
2014 be a lot of people where it's,
you know, I was like, there's birth tee
shirt. I've seen him like different years.
One day. I have no
idea. I've never of that
good memory though. Whatever
it is. You're right.
Actually, I didn't even know that Mexican
and the United States was in the same
different tribes of native
native Americans have lived
in the area that is now
California for an estimated
13 to 15,000 years.
Holy Shit, man. Holy Shit.
Wow. During the pre European, uh, period,
there was only a between a hundred
and 300,000 native Americans living in
California. Wow. There's no
one here is crazy. Just empty.
Isn't that weird?
300,000 is not answer those questions
when he's saying it's probably an amazing,
I mean, look, it's probably
a hard life even back then,
but how amazing must've been
to be on horseback and shit.
300,000 people here. Well,
actually pre European.
The problem with that is pre European.
Um,
I don't think they were on horses at all.
The, the horses came from the Europeans,
I'm pretty sure. Yeah.
They're riding horses.
Like that was one of the things like
where Cortez showed up and Montezuma's
people like what the fuck these guys are
gods because they were on horses that
they were parked. Yeah, yeah.
Of, of, of the hosts. Yeah.
Fascinating shit man.
1821 that is not that long ago.
Less than 200 years ago. This was
Mexico. And wonder why Mexicans get mad.
That shit's really recent.
It's last life if you don't have
that many generations either. No,
not at all. That's not that many at all.
This like great, great grandparents.
I can almost remember
that shit. Yeah. Wow.
I think I saw somewhere the
other day that Columbus,
Ohio now has a bigger population
of Mexicans than white people,
I think is what, I'll double check on
that, but Columbus, Ohio, and we just,
I remember when I lived there just some
10 or 11 years ago, it was like I saw,
I remember seeing the first Mexican. I
remember like, what's that? You know,
and my mom's like,
that's a Mexican.
Everyday I'm hustling everyday.
I'm hustling.
They figured out a way
to just fucking hustles.
They've got all the way up to Columbus,
like these fucking chubby white people
aren't working. Let's go take their jobs,
kick some ass, take some names.
I'll take five jobs, please.
We're all living in a one bedroom
apartment, saving money, boom.
Next thing you know, they're opening up
a taco joint. Best Tacos in Columbus.
Dude's not even legal.
And it's like,
it's fine if there's two taco places in
town and one of them was a dude that's
not even legal. I'm going
to that guy's place. Yeah.
He's bringing over goats and shit service.
Some nasty,
vicious Jalapenos.
That one place man in
La Jolla across the street from the condo.
What's that place called?
Shade asked me too fast.
Deep Bob's Burrito,
Don's Don,
whatever it is.
It's so close to Mexico.
It's just the most authentic,
the most ridiculously good burrito's
you'll ever have in your life by design.
And it's in San Diego, so it's like
real close to the actual Mexico.
You can't play Don Lucas, Don Lucas,
you can't play when you're in San Diego.
You can't have some shitty Mexican food.
Mexico's right.
They're literally on the doorstep.
Yeah. It's a weird moment,
man. When you have um, you know,
this incredible community
like La Jolla and on this uh,
like really rich area. Yeah.
Beautiful, beautiful era. And then
20 minute drive,
Tijuana,
20 minute drive, like a complete different
country, you know, wrecked with poverty,
drug violence,
crazy.
Turn it around Europe are realizing how
many countries you can cover in a few
hours drive.
I mean,
that's insane that you're driving through
Germany to France, to Holland, to Italy.
All of these, uh, uh, uh, uh,
within a day kind of thing is,
but you're in a completely different
country and culture, language, everything.
Yeah. I, you guys can go to
France and Germany and Hungary.
Like how many different places can you
leave in England and get two in one day
and sign them out and sign it if you
literally drive in through or drive. Yeah.
This, so many. And they all say how
many of them speak different languages?
All of them.
It's crazy.
They're like across the board from each
other and completely different languages.
But most of them speak English as
well. Yeah. Yeah. When you get respect,
when you're doing gigs,
do you do gigs in all these
countries and do English gigs?
Yeah. Wow. That's crazy. It was,
it was crazy because obviously
it's quite a lyric based.
We assumed when we first started
going out there that that,
that they wouldn't really get that side
of it. But it's crazy how in Europe,
a lot of people seem to get
it more because they read
the translations of it and
a paying attention, more
of, you know, it means,
so if you're hearing it and you speak
English, you're going to miss tons of it,
but you're just, you're
picking up enough. Whereas,
cause they're not picking up any other
than go and read the a word for word and
understand it far more than half of the
British people who come to our shows and
stuff like that.
That's kind of cool because it's all fast.
So if you're like, oh, this is
my language, then you won't get,
there's tons of hip hop songs.
I don't know half of it,
but I've listened to it a
million times and you just, yeah,
yeah.
Like doing that as an APP,
releasing it as an APP and
having all your lyrics.
Well, the lyrics on there now, that
could be good that way. I mean,
I've always been adamant of putting it in,
in the booklet and shit like that.
I've always been adamant on the packaging,
always having or being good.
I like physical stuff. Obviously
I'm adapting to the digital stuff,
but I like to put out a nice
f f a physical product as
well with all the lyrics
in,
and then I kind of sit there,
we'll kind of snotty on online when
people ask me the lyrics, it's like, Whoa,
you'd bought the CD then? Yeah. Just going
to buy the album. You'll find the APP.
Yeah. It's like, do you get upset
with people? Bootlegger shit,
I get upset that there's no shame over it.
And that kills me now that people
openly just tweet, you're going, yeah,
I stole that. It's like, cool,
I understand that that happens,
but don't come to my face and told me
that cause these are released most of it
on my own label now and stuff like that.
It's just like,
you're not ripping anyone
off other than me. Um, yeah.
But do you feel like,
um,
there's a balance with people finding
out about your stuff because someone will
take it and download it and then they'll,
they'll distribute it and then
other people find out about them,
more people come to your shows?
I think we completely is. I think,
um, yeah, it's, it's all a kind of is,
it's all interwoven.
But I think people often argue are so I
stole your music but I paid to come to
see you live. It's like, yeah, not
performed live for you. Right, right.
That's what you were paying for this
gentlemen. That doesn't say that.
That doesn't cover the
receiving almost this,
it's like if you're going to do it yet,
it might find,
you might hear some and have some new
listeners cause he told somebody but don't
go to your, like you say, go
to your face and it's such,
I find it's such a weird
argument the saying, um,
saying I stole this bar, I
paid for this. When you're the,
you're paying for has
its own value anyway.
It's like saying I'm not going
to pay you at work this week,
but I paid you for the last
three weeks so, so we're cool.
So no, we're not cool. This
is for this, this word. Right,
right, right, right, right.
No,
I do a lot to try and cause make it
engaging and my people want to pay on my
solo album. I released a fake
tolerant that was all this, oh,
the instrument or was,
but me just talking and just chatting and
doing kind of a DVD extras kind of, oh,
the drummer on this track was with Travis
Barker and shit and shit like that.
And going through stuff just so that
the Torah, and that was first out.
Then everyone grabbed,
it wasn't at the hour,
but then it also kind of not
in a preachy way, kind of said,
if you're stealing it, you're
stealing it from, from me,
from the artists that you're into
and support in this light. So yeah.
And that kind of works. A lot of
people say, ah Shit, I got caught.
I got caught on the fake terror. And
that's interesting that, you know,
I try a lot to try and be, yeah, try
and make things interesting in that way.
Because again, if people are gonna
steal, they're going to steal.
But we get an awful lot of people who say,
I've not paid for an hour,
been in ages, but I paid for
your album because of, yeah.
The way it's all coming from a personal
perspective. Right. Because it's
someone directly you release it. Yeah.
Yeah. That's kind of, you know, there's,
there's a lot of things that people don't
want to pay for online. Yeah. You know,
and once they start being able to
get things for free, they don't,
they don't want to pay for them.
It's finding the balance and,
and the sweet spot,
I've just released my spoken word show,
Edinburgh fringe,
so it's kind of spoken word,
but then have some stand in
there as well kind of thing.
And it stunned me that the comedy world,
Louie and yourself and everyone had found
that thing of putting out for $5 and
being direct to the customer for $5 is
enough for you to not want to go on a
torrent site and hunted down.
It seems to be that sweet spot
that people will be happy to pay.
Yet the music industry hasn't
done that. It's a, for my shower,
I've done that and released it in that
way. And again, it seems to be working.
People are kind of I that people like you,
they'll buy it and if
they wouldn't buy it,
they would probably never going to buy
it anyway. And if they download it,
you'll get more people downloading it.
So I don't know how many people
have illegally downloaded my shit,
but a lot of people have bought it,
so it's, I think it all worked out.
I just think it works out spreads the
word, but it again, again, it's not,
I'm completely, I finding that's the
way things go long. I started off,
I think you've got to do a
certain amount of free stuff.
I think that's totally key.
You need to be giving away stuff for free
and engage in and building that crowd
so that hopefully when you do have stuff
for sale, yeah, people will pay well.
I think that definitely makes it a better,
better relationship than if everything
you do is just for sale. Yeah. You know,
I think when you give people stuff for
free, I mean certainly like a podcast.
Have you ever thought about
doing something like a
podcast? I'm tempted. I've,
I've, I've had a ride Ayrshire in the, in
the UK for the last, uh, year and a half.
I've just stopped that
now for a bit of a break,
but I'm considering going the podcast
route instead. Yeah, why not? I mean,
when you have a radio show,
the thing about it is you're always
going to be working for somebody.
You're always going to be
uploading something if someone
else's servers and they
have to decide whether or not
unscrupulous is getting crazy.
This motherfucker saying some
shit that I don't agree with.
We're going to have to remove
them from [inaudible]. Exactly.
That kind of just being your
own boss on that is. Yeah.
And much like you do with
your spoken word stuff,
you're the creator of this stuff.
You know,
you'd be the creator of
your own podcast too. Yeah,
I think I've completely forgot that I had,
and refinish thing I mentioned
is six filters on my website,
but if you went to the codeword Rogan
is $5 at the moment. So you know, I've,
I've, I've, I've, I've seen
your adverts and know it works.
I know how to when people open,
so scrupulous pip.co. Dot. UK.
Oh, there you go. Dot. Broken UK.
Yeah. Okay, cool. Awesome man.
I forgot about that.
I saw at that four came in.
What are you doing over
in America right now I'm,
I'm working on a new solo album,
so I'm working on that with a Travis
Barker again at that Ilona from nine inch
nails. Don't wait for those with Eddie
Bravo. Yeah, Eddie was over last night.
He's Travis seems like a cool guy.
I've never met him,
but we've gone back and forth online.
I've communicated with the season.
The last time I was over here and
again, he's fucking, he's huge.
He doesn't need to give anyone would be
nice. Yeah. I came over and he was just,
he gave us about two hours in his studio
of just him playing dramas and for the
record was like a dream,
a dream anymore and just to just,
we chatted online and he played
on a track I've done previously,
but it was all over emails and just
the most accommodating and nice go on.
It's like, well, you don't have to be
this guy. You could be a complete Dick.
He Kit. But he's, yeah, just played for
hours and literally as soon as I left,
I had a message from him saying, you need
anymore. Just let me know if you know,
if you're in town. Oh cool. Great.
Yeah. That's amazing. Yeah, he's about as
big as it gets it. It comes to drummers.
Yeah.
Does that guy have any room for tattoos
or is he just like completely filled up?
He still seems to be having them all
the time, but [inaudible] tattoos.
Yeah. Yeah. He's got no room, man.
It's a, I liked that too though.
He does a lot of martial arts
training too. Does is a place, yeah.
A place near here that he,
we started talking was, was
us talking about a UFC
events and epics and that,
that's kind of how we got to get
to know each other, so, yeah.
Yeah.
He loves it.
I'm just saying he's a big MMA fan and
he's always tweeting about and stuff.
That's cool, man. So listen, we're,
we're out of time. We did three hours.
Could believe that shit.
Fuck. Damn it flew by. It did.
It did. But thank you for,
first of all,
thank you for letting us play your music
on the show and thanks for coming on
and just having a chat. It
was fun. Thanks for them.
Neon. Yeah, pleased to be here.
And what was the, the the thing that
I wish I could say besides proper,
uh, for someone with an F,
I wasn't straight away or
straight away, the worst report
ever. I was thinking, in fact,
no, that's you're always thinking.
Now Ladies and gentlemen,
the fucking show is over and we thank
you. We thank you very, very much.
Uh, thanks to me undies.
Go to me undies.com.
You dirty for seven years.
No change in underwear.
Motherfuckers go to me on these.com
forward slash Rogen and get 20% off your
first order by September 1st.
That's me,
undies.com/rogan and
thanks also to nature box.
Go to naturebox. Do we do naturebox
naturebox last one. So yeah,
thanks to naturebox anyway. Uh, if
you want a free naturebox commercial,
go to naturebox.com forward slash Rogen
and you'll get 50% off your months.
First box. And thanks. Also the ting,
go to rogan.ting.com and save 25
bucks off of any of their new phones.
Oh yeah. I'm to hit this weekend.
I'm with Ryan sickler and, uh,
Sam Aaa at Velvet Jones in Santa Barbara.
Powerful Santa Barbara. Yeah, that's an
awesome spot. Yeah. I love Santa Barbara.
It's one of my favorite
cities. All right. So, uh,
you could find out that and more on death
squad.tv along with all of Brian's a
products, the kitty cat shirts that he
creates all himself and all that stuff.
And, uh, we'll be back next week.
A lot of more podcasts for you,
ladies and gentlemen, until then, have
you solves a beautiful life? Big Kiss.
[inaudible].